Twitter is still of course functioning
but uh based on the title of this
episode Twitter is dead is a figure of
speech engagement is way down and I
noticed this earlier people have been
talking about it for several weeks and
people have been talking about how if
you lock your profile on Twitter
you'll get more engagement
that doesn't seem to make sense to me
something's wrong with the machine and
we had this story as Twitter thread from
Dave Rubin last week where he talked
about the fractal Rube Goldberg machine
that was Twitter and that there were
actually secret codes new codes that
were censoring conservatives they were
censoring people like Dave Rubin so the
reason why I say it's dead is because
two things happen engagement disappeared
something happened in the algorithm a
couple weeks ago where all of a sudden
people stopped getting comments replies
they stopped getting retweets stop
getting quote tweets they stopped
getting likes and everybody said yo
what's going on it feels like Twitter is
dying people aren't engaging anymore
maybe everybody States Twitter now I
doubt it something changed in the system
today everyone started locking their
accounts and mass and there's just I
don't know I unfollowed maybe like two
dozen people and I didn't unfollow them
because I'm mad at them they locked
their accounts I can see their tweets
but I can't engage I can't share the
tweet I can't I can't let other people
know like hey this thing is happening
all of the quote tweets I already had
from these people gone
quote tweets from people I didn't follow
before Gone locking their accounts I'm
sorry whatever is going on the platform
is in a in a dire situation right now so
let me just add it's a slow news day did
you notice but uh we'll we'll talk about
this because we do have the Twitter
thread from Dave Rubin we didn't get
into on the show
last week and then I'll just show you
the general reaction from a lot of
people as to what's going on and what it
means
if people aren't getting engagement on
the platform they're going to stop using
it so we'll see I mean what are people
doing to migrate to uh to tick tock or
something and we do have a bunch of
other stories I mean there's creepy
stuff about Joe Biden we can talk about
that but we have some more interesting
cultural stuff we got a personality for
prageru
went into YouTube signed up and cl and
said they were a young child and what
they were fed was a bunch of weird
consent queer consent videos like
telling 9 through 12 year olds about how
they can consent if you know yeah no
like so that's just kind of weird so
we'll talk about that plus we have we
got to talk about this MSNBC thing this
MSNBC host who says that she got a cold
in December
and then felt pain in her heart turned
out she had pericarditis the doctor said
it was from first that she had reflux
it's been a month and a half and she
says she still has now myocarditis or
some kind of heart issue and it's like
if it was from a cold can a can the
common cold cause myocarditis for a
month and a half like you still have
this cold so this is interesting because
MSNBC dedicated a full segment to this
and brought on a doctor to talk about it
and it's making people talk about these
wild theories about what really happened
so we'll get into that but before we get
started my friends head over to
timcast.com become a member to support
our work click that join us button if
you would like to help the machine keep
on a churning if you like this show and
you like the work that we do joining us
is the best way to support the work
we're doing and of course as you know we
are setting up our physical location
where people can come and hang out and
that's going to be in West Virginia we
had uh we have the the plans are coming
in for the ball we're gonna build we
were talking today about Ian's Crystal
Cove it's going to be super late you can
hang out in a little weird Crystal
mushroom space and watch watch shows
just like Ian Wood just like I would
that's okay just like it would and so uh
with your support as members we're
trying to impact cultural spaces and so
uh we could use your support don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining us tonight to
talk about this and uh anything else is
Malcolm Flex hello hello hello glad to
be here guys
um before we get started first off can
we bow our heads we need to say a prayer
for all of my brothers out there in
relationships with Latinas why is that
trust me you'll you'll want to say the
prayer all right
oh man okay there we go what what is
that about what's going on spicy Latinas
are our thing man like I said again okay
I thought there's like something in the
news or something happening okay oh no I
don't know so who are you man what are
you doing so uh my name is Malcolm Flix
I am what you could call a high capacity
assault poster oh wow yeah I know
and now I am a post analyst but now
I'm just uh just a normal bro man to do
fighting I do uh football pretty much uh
you know politics science
you name it the design stuff you're
talking about we're talking about
pericarditis and myocarditis a moment
ago and you were talking about a bunch
of stuff I didn't understand but we can
get in all that with the MSNBC story
yeah you're not a doctor but you have
massive medical experience you work as a
what is the title of your your role
pretty much MSL so Medical Science to
Liaison yeah it's fascinating you carry
that mic around take it up and down so
you have to lean over anytime yeah man
it's cool we'll talk about thanks for
hanging out we got Hannah Claire Brimley
hanging out hi I'm Hannah clay brimlow
I'm a writer for timcast.com
I'm Ian Crossland happy to be here
what's up everybody
um nothing too much to report I did take
or bucko to a local vet earlier and
things are moving swimmingly we're going
to have his stem cell injections this
week so I'll keep you updated post a
little picture of bucko yesterday on my
Twitter and I would like to keep rolling
from here if anything comes up I'll
mention it on the show right on and I am
at serve.com unvaxed unlocked on Twitter
well all right what a great slime
let's jump into this first story and
here's why there's two reasons why we
decided we're gonna we're gonna open up
this show leading with uh the Twitter
being dead Story the first and most
important thing is that it's um it's a
very slow news day nothing is lit
nothing's going on and this is the most
important thing to talk about no I'm
just kidding um it is a slow news day
there is some other stuff we can talk
about but I really thought it'd be super
boring to just be like another
development in the hunter Biden story in
their you know the fed's rated uh
Biden's pen was it the Penn Biden Center
whatever and that happened in November
and no one knew it happened until now so
it's like of course there's weird
corrupt stuff going on but I'm just like
let's talk about something more
interesting so I go on Twitter and a
bunch of people I follow you can see
this meme Alx says opening up Twitter
right now all the locked profiles
everyone started everyone but a lot of
people started locking their profiles
high profile accounts started locking
their profiles so that no one can
retweet their content no one can share
their content yo you combine that with
the fact that already people were
reporting for the past couple of weeks a
weird algorithm change that resulted in
zero engagement and it feels like
Twitter is just totally dead this feels
like and I'm sure these people will un
private their account at some point but
it feels like how like Canada's like
offering assisted suicide to people like
if you want to kill yourself we'll make
it easy if you want to block out your
social media so we don't have to ban you
we'll make it you know maybe they can
incentivize you to ban yourself so
exactly self-selecting and they're like
removing themselves from the gene pool
so this is the crazy thing right I I
retweeted Chris Martinson a doctor Chris
Martin we've been on the show
he he was talking about the MSNBC host I
brought up in the intro she she gets a
common cold but that results in
pericarditis and myocarditis I'm going
through my tweets because I I look at my
own tweets it's kind of like bookmarking
so when I retweet something I know like
here's the story I wanted I wanted to
post and it says this tweet is
unavailable because the account owner
protects his his tweets and I'm like oh
but I know Chris Martin said he's been
on the show before can't see his tweets
anymore he went private people are
basically Banning themselves anything I
shared from these accounts gone anybody
who follows me can't see him
it's it's like come on like these people
have it is strange to me that they were
convinced the only way to retain
engagement was to actually shut their
accounts down it's dead internet Theory
taken to like a whole new level but you
know honestly maybe maybe no no joke
what if what was really happening with
Twitter was that Twitter was falsely
boosting the numbers on tweets to make
it seem like there was engagement to
trick advertisers into spending money
and now that Elon Musk is cleaning up
the code he accidentally removed
whatever fake thing was there that
generated fake comments or fake likes
I'm not even playing it was the uh I
think the CEO of Reddit uh Alexis uh
what's his name Alexis Ohanian is that
his name
um actually no Serena Williams right
yeah yeah yeah I know the guy he's a
very nice guy and I'm pretty sure him
and uh what's the other guy's name
Huffman talked about how in the early
days of Reddit they would pretend to be
users so that people would think there
was they were talking to people because
if you go on a social media platform and
comment known response you're like I'm
bored I leave so they would pretend to
be different people and comment and
create fake conversations and now
they'll ban you for doing that on Reddit
that's right oh yeah no I mean unless
you're you know the government I used to
do with mines I'd go on there and I'd
make a post a mines thing and then I'd
go on with my personal account be like
this is really cool upvote upvote
everyone when I was working as an admin
all the big tech companies they found
out they'd Banned Me instantly what if
that's it and the reason why when you
lock your account you get engagement is
because there's the locked engagement
fluffer and there's the uh unprivate
engagement fluffer I call them fluffers
you know what I mean like yeah you know
just make them big and uh and they only
got rid of the code on one of them dude
it does it makes me laugh because it's
like so many people who you know have
lauded other people for basically like
following Trends and you know just like
chasing the like chasing the clout and
now all of a sudden you know you're
seeing people like what's going on man I
only got 100 likes all and like they
wake up and the next day with like cold
sweats because they literally are not
getting the same engagements like is it
blows my mind just like whatever how
hardwired people are to Twitter yeah
like and Instagram all of it man I feel
like Elon Musk is just like he's running
experiments and collecting data for the
aliens he's like hmm I wonder if they
deprived them of uh how are they going
to react and everyone everyone's
dopamine just dropped by like 80 and
they're like
like what are we doing Bros what like
what are we doing I thought we had real
lives we thought we touched the most
grass out of everybody on Twitter like
it reminds me of like I'm panning for
gold like uh there because I think
people are trying to find a way to crack
the algorithm back in the day on YouTube
if you could figure out how to post on
everyone's page at once then all of a
sudden your channel broke through the
algorithm and people could get really
famous in a relatively short amount of
time on social networks but a lot of
these networks now are like you know
they're ready for that so they're trying
to stop it from happening but people are
still like hoping they find some gold in
the river sift dude it used to be on
YouTube that you'd make a video where
you're talking about a George W bush and
you know the war in Iraq but the
thumbnail was just like a big a big
tittied woman about I'm not even kidding
because people would click on it and so
you're like I don't know I'm not I'm not
a woman but if I'm gonna get those
clicks and the thumbnail would be like a
guy going like this and it would be like
war in Iraq and it'll be just like a big
large breasted woman next to him and
then it would get a million hits and
they used to do this thing too where
they would uh they would make videos
with fake thumbnails and fake titles and
when you clicked it it would just play
like it would show like a sentence and
it would play music and they would get
massively thumbs down but they generated
tons of hits YouTube started to clean
this up like okay we can't allow this
but if you look at some of the earliest
YouTubers and go look at their like big
ones and look at their YouTube channels
you will see they just for some reason
tended to have thumbnails that needed to
talk about women in bikinis Lisa Nova uh
huge in 2006 seven and I remember the
one the video that really popped off the
thumbnail was just a big butt crack and
all of a sudden it got millions of
clicks it was and I don't think it was
her butt crack it was like smg's butt
crack shout out to Castle well there was
uh there's also Casey neistat's famous
video Make It Count remember this one no
it's the one where he said that he was
given a budget to produce a commercial
for for a Nike and instead of doing that
he just traveled around the world in in
10 days because it was more fun
something like that and then ended up
being an amazing commercial but the
thumbnail for it is two women in bikinis
like posing and him taking a picture so
that like like people knew exactly what
they were doing with how they engaged
the crazy thing to me is that we've
we've created a points system for our
lives we've video gamified yes politics
and life like with Twitter these are
political personalities being like I'm
not getting engagement anymore so I'm
going to lock my account to get more
engagement and I'm like that sounds like
someone made a mousetrap and put peanut
butter in it and you were like I'm gonna
go in there and get that peanut butter
and then your account gets locked all
your retweets are gone all your quote
tweets are gone it is it's like yo
somebody at Twitter figured out how to
ban the conservatives in One Sweep by
getting them to walk into the Trap
themselves that's hilarious bro but
there are tons of people who aren't on
Twitter who like if you explain this
like everyone's locking their account
it's a big deal they're gonna be like
what I don't understand because like
Twitter feeds itself right like when
things start to irritate people on
Twitter it circles around like there are
parts of Twitter that won't care about
anything that's going on engagement is
sort of universal like trying to drive
traffic to your profile is like the one
unifying front through all of Twitter
and even then there are tons of people
who don't use the platform who who don't
care about this hey let's just call it
what it is bro like
we discovered the meta the like the the
one meta build on Twitter and the mods
got mad and they patched it and now
everybody's all just like freaking out
so honestly I'm trying to figure this
out what if all the conservatives just
kind of like lock their accounts or
everybody's conservative and independent
just like their accounts and the
journalists literally can't like write
hit pieces anymore that's what I'm
thinking that we should all just like
it's actually a good point I was gonna I
was gonna say that all of these accounts
that locked their tweets like they're
all these all these people that like
their accounts all the news articles
that have recorded those tweets gone
they're now going to show Dead Space oh
man oh if they unlock their account they
don't they don't repopulate right I
think it will go back you think so yeah
yeah because that'd be interesting too
if you just like periodically like lock
your account for 24 hours so like if
anyone who's used your stuff can't get
access to it yeah look I like Elon I
like Elon Musk you know I'm glad that he
got Twitter I'm glad he released Twitter
files I think he could do better but you
know he's doing what he can but I got to
be honest if Twitter I woke up tomorrow
and it was gone I'd I'd be happy I'd use
mines it's just a piece of tech it's
same as YouTube like internet video is
where it's at it doesn't matter what
network you're on internet video is the
powerful tool yeah
um I think that a lot of these problems
people are see searching for a way to
break an algorithm that they don't
understand because the code is private
if the code was public and you could see
what the algorithm is doing you would
know whether or not this was going to
have any value locking your hand you
wouldn't have to do it are you saying we
should free the code yeah yeah drink
free the code baby there we go guys
someone suggested me and you arm wrestle
I don't think it's gonna happen dude are
you ready I don't think I could take you
with two arms
I don't know maybe two legs two legs and
two arms actually I got to be honest I'm
pretty sure you could just like lift Ian
with one arm bicep girl yeah what's an
average one arm bicep curl dude average
is probably like 40. but then again I
mean my wife she curls like 30 pound
dumbbells so she's kind of skewing
extremely high on that so
yeah honestly for me uh I think about 70
or 80 like dude imagine this news is so
slow I'm actually going to come off them
guess and just talk about my biceps it's
pretty interesting think about that
there was some news today uh the Biden
stuff and I'm just like I don't I don't
care man look we get it the bidens are
crooked they're dirty people and I
started thinking about this jackpot I
did a segment of 4 pm Jeff wrote about
his old neighborhood when he was a kid
and how it's falling apart and crime
ridden and then I'm just like yeah
that's the result it it's they're
actually all symptoms of the same thing
cultural fragmentation I was saying that
you know you go back imagine a small
town of 3000 people and you've got a
nice God-fearing white family a nice
God-fearing black family a nice
God-fearing Latino family my point is
they uh Asian family they they agree
culturally and ideologically on their
world view race doesn't matter their
views on morality are all the same so if
one guy loses his job and goes on
unemployment no nobody's mad about it
they're like we got your back buddy you
know don't worry we'll see you at church
on Sunday and he's like I'm gonna keep
trying I know you guys are there for me
then eventually finds a a job no one is
you know when when everybody agrees with
each other and wants to be part of the
same Community they're not looking to
exploit each other they're not looking
to commit crimes against each other they
got each other's back social programs
work crime is low you don't need police
and then I started thinking about what
what the Biden family represents and
it's just like
they're they're both a symptom of and
the cause of it's it's like it's like a
Whirlpool you get when you have a
fractured moral society and people just
stop caring and you get Democrats who
are like I'm voting for this guy simply
because I hate you then the people they
end up voting for like the bidens are
crime families
and then because you end up with a crime
family in government they end up burning
everything to the ground he's kind of
like a that's not quite an old wash-up
politician he's kind of like an old
washed up politician like after 1988
when he was plagiarizing in his
presidential run he had to drop out of
the race he was pretty much laughed at
scorned and like never taken seriously
again until all of a sudden Obama
puts him as his VP he runs he looks like
a daughtering old man in 19 in 2008 no
one took him seriously with his run
against Obama and then all of a sudden I
guess now we find out it was the
establishment that it's the DNC it's
like the Democratic party that selects
the running mate I thought Obama put him
in as like oh I want an old white guy I
want like a business guy to like
represent that business part because I'm
the rebel no man you remember they ran
it by him and then Biden was and then
Biden had that Infamous little script
where he was like you know we at the
first clean well-spoken black guy and
you know it was like a fairy you know
they literally had the place set up and
so it's just it's it's kind of funny
because you know Tim you were saying
it's just like all of all the people
hate each other and they vote candidates
in just despite other people well then
that means Biden is literally just like
an embodiment of the hatred and contempt
that Americans have for each other yeah
you see that in how they govern they
have hatred and contempt for us you know
and the way they conduct themselves
right like I have never found a reason
to write about it but like Hunter Biden
has this illegitimate child who he won't
acknowledge even though he puts her mom
on the payroll for a while and like now
her mom who I believe was a stripper I'm
not sure
um is like trying to get her daughter to
have the Biden last name so that she is
you know acknowledged she's connected
because it's beneficial to be to be
known in America as a Biden and to me
like this is someone who doesn't
acknowledge this child like it sounds
horrible to to saddle your child with
the name of a man who doesn't want to
acknowledge her who had another child
after who they bring out for photos like
it's he's resistant he's he's trying to
stop this he has asked the judge to Pro
to uh to not let this happen meanwhile
Grandma Joe Biden like brings his
toddler son that he had in wedlock with
this South African film director like
they present themselves to this family
and they love the young women and
they're so supportive and then really on
the other hand like they don't they
don't practice anything they preach and
we see this time and time again right
like no one is perfect but it's
different to say oh this is the package
we're selling you America and please
ignore the other stuff right like it's
it's just corrupt morally it's like
someone took like all the negative
things of like
it's like somebody had done does not
understand American culture except for
the bad things basically took and
distilled all of the worst aspects drugs
fatherless children money laundering
corruption and just like literally just
embedded them into Biden family at that
point and that's like literally what we
have so but Vogue did a cover of Naomi
Biden's wedding so we should just accept
that they are like the beautiful new
Americana family like it makes me sad
right like if these like Tiffany Trump
and I'm gonna make this point because
I've been thinking about it for weeks
and have not had a chance to do it to
make it but Tiffany Trump got married
the weekend before Naomi Biden right
very similar Styles very lavish wedding
both like from powerful families but
like Naomi Biden's is good and it's
representational even though her family
actually has all this Scandal and all
this weird connection and they treat
each other each other strangely and the
Trump family for by all accounts like is
unusual right a man who's been divorced
three times has all these kids like not
super typical but by all accounts all of
the siblings get along really well but
they're the bad family they're
representation of negative family
politics like it doesn't really make
sense this is this is why I did the
segment I did at 4 P.M on my on my main
Channel normally you know because
normally what I do every day is I grab
like the big story and I'm like here's
the thing that happened here's what it
means here's what's going on here's some
other stuff about it and like the other
day I was talking about oh Biden scandal
the emails apparently Hunter Biden
emails from his laptop suggests he had
access to classified information and it
seems like in emails they were directly
getting information straight from the
White House so that's a big Scandal
today there was more information on it
that they had rated the Penn Biden
Center or whatever and so there's like
the FBI were doing raids on the bidens
for a while now before the midterms and
they weren't telling us and then I was
just like thinking about uh Chuck Todd
Jim Jordan goes on uh goes on Meet the
Press and he says you know Chuck Todd's
like but Trump had classified documents
and he's like Trump is the president and
they were guarded by the Secret Service
and they were locked up and Biden had
him set him in his garage and then just
for tribal reasons Chuck Todd says no no
like you can't see it you know it's a
it's a conspiracy and it's just like we
we get it those of us of sound mind
Chuck Todd is just saying whatever he
has to because there is a cult of people
who don't care what's true they care
that they are right so you can come out
and make your argument and they don't
care literally don't care and I'm just
thinking about all this and I'm like
then I saw Jack besobic's article about
how his neighborhood fell apart and I'm
like yeah it's because we have no
cultural cohesion we have no uh shared
moral framework and so we end up with
leaders who are basically on the Titanic
watching the iceberg coming
right before it hits they run grab a
whole bunch of silverware and jump in a
Lifeboat and just cast off and instead
of actually steering the ship saving
people or being like a real Captain and
saying you know last person off the ship
or you go down with it they're off the
ship first and they don't even tell you
what happened no no worse they're
telling you everything's fine don't
worry guys go go back to the mini bar
get some more drinks go go gamble just
get off the dick peace little Iceberg
the ship starts yeah that's right the
ship starts sinking starts going up and
people are sliding don't worry this is
the slide function it's fun glasses are
flying out people are hanging from the
side like everything's still fine the
ground is flat no don't question
meanwhile there are there there's a
second ship that pulled up uh funded by
the Chinese Communist party and they're
they're rowing over being like don't
worry about it Hunter get the boat
that's exactly what they're doing I
think that's I think a lot of the
business dealings Hunter Biden is doing
is basically
like these people are running this
country into the ground in more ways
than one from from neighborhoods falling
apart to the tribalistic nature of
humans uh of of of society right now I'm
wondering if their attitude is just like
look one man's not going to fix this
grab what you can every man for himself
I've been thinking about oh we're gonna
say no it's about to say it's like a
multi-layered hedge basically you know
you already know it's going to burn down
so why not extract all the wealth that
you can that way when it burns down
you're you know sitting kind of pretty
looking like royalty then you can come
back and the ashes are there and you can
suddenly say hey guys we have money we
can fix this and then you basically take
all the credit rebuild it everybody's
ground down and depressed it's kind of
like you know Russia post-soviet
collapse really where you know that's
that's why all the drinking rusky you
know sort of uh you know those
stereotypes come from because when the
Soviet collapsed they basically gave
Russian people all these waivers and you
know things like this when these people
couldn't even feed themselves and so
then basically you had the oligarchs and
the American Banks basically come over
and buy up all almost all the industry
and you know turn Russians into
basically slave slave workers and then
next thing you know well it's back but
now the oligarchs run everything and
they've already got all the money yeah I
got an idea if it's all going to come
crashing down go buy some chickens
man because uh
the people who are able to sustain
themselves more than others are going to
be better off if this is the trend that
continues I do think there's an
alternative that's why I said we need to
make America great again and I don't
know if I'm saying it in the exact same
way that all the Trump supporters saying
about but but I imagine probably when
Jack was up it brings up Pizza Hut when
he was a kid and there's a salad bar and
if you read a book in school they gave
you a free donut and you got a free I
don't know there's a bunch all I
remember was something that's all I
remember because I remember I get there
was a Pizza next to a Dunkin Donuts so
I'd get the free pizza and then we were
leaving and go get a free donut there
was other stuff on it like something it
was like drug addiction like they give
you the cheese and the high fructose
corn syrup and the sauce with the sugar
in your gum good old days
didn't know that we were a war now bro I
doubt back then they had all that stuff
it was like after 92 it was when the
high fructose started coming in but we
were living in a haze of ignorance at
that time you know what though maybe the
decline of literacy levels because I
know you guys see in the schools how
like kids can't even read anymore
it started when they took away the
personal pan pieces that's when it
happened
now you see how they're tweeting oh my
God it gives me a headache bro it's just
just all the it's all like a court
stenographer shorthand and yeah yeah and
I grew and honestly I grew up with it
like you know I don't know if you guys
know this but I'm black and so you know
obviously we have our own kind of like
you know our own dialect in our own
vernacular and stuff I assumed you're a
white supremacist dude I know I know did
you see those five guys though Jesus
Christ black people anymore man these
white people out here crazy but nah bro
like white supremacists man yeah Dave
Chappelle called it what were you saying
we do reality no no no no so you're
black please continue I know I know I
know I hierarchy guys hierarchy but uh
but no it's it's just sort of funny you
know when you start to think about it
you know I grew up in a weird like we
used our own vernacular in our own
dialect when we talked and it was mainly
just because you know it was shorthand
certain words we just didn't know how to
for now now you see people out here
purposely typing like purposely
misspelling and like the errors and just
uh the misuse of their and it gives me
palpitations oh it's hard for me man
like where are all the semicolons you
know they exist for a reason it's two
different subjects in one sentence
there's no comma use the semicolon to
delineate the two subjects I'm gonna
write you a note and I'm going to leave
in your room it's going to have no
semicolons and improper punctuation I'm
gonna puke on myself hey I wanna I wanna
tag on what you're saying about the
oligarchs earlier because this has been
crossing my mind last night I'm like
okay this Russian invasion or Ukraine
it's not Putin I mean Putin's one of
them it's the out the Russian oligarchs
that are in charge it's it's basically a
hyper capitalist state of oligarchs are
running that thing and it's no wonder
they want to conquer a trade port in
Sebastopol they want that trade because
it's what hyper capitalists would do in
Civilization if you were playing against
them and they had a government run by a
bunch of uber people just like
capitalists so but I'm wondering
for the capitalists of the United States
the oligarchs the United States if they
want to control the world they would
want to Ally with the capitalists of
Russia against I would think either they
they're too stupid and they think that
really they can beat them
um in a sort of attrition or it's uh
they're intentionally taking us to war
to kill off the common man so that like
you said earlier they could come back
and rebuild with all their finances
that's where you're wrong kiddo because
these aren't regular capitalists these
are crony capitalists right crony
capitalists don't care about free
marketing competition they just want to
fix the game for them to win but you
know it's funny you bring that up
because actually you know Russian now
the oligarch problem isn't near as bad
as it used to be like I don't know if
you guys know this but when the IMF came
in and they tried to do what was called
shock therapy where you convert a
formerly communist Nation to a
capitalist Nation the oligarchs botched
the whole thing on purpose because they
want to buy all the infrastructure up
for cheap Putin when he came to power
actually drove most of those oligarchs
out of Russia and guess where they went
Ukraine Ukraine and to the US so a lot
of this anti-pudent sentiment that we
see you know Putin's listen let's go for
what he is I mean I'm not saying he's a
good guy but you know compared to some
of the other Russian leaders the people
of the Russian Federation he's actually
a moderate you know I've heard that uh
and you know you can't take my word for
the gospel but a lot of Russians are you
know pretty frustrated that he pity
patted you know with the war that he had
this kind of kid's glove approach with
Ukraine to begin with and then you know
when they uh brought in shirovicin or
general Armageddon basically now they're
going full scale anyways and they're
just like why didn't you do that you
know before and it's you know it's kind
of crazy how we have all this anti-you
know Russian rhetoric going anyways but
it's just
old oligarchs of the past and you know
angry Rich Boomers with a uh you know
War grudge against Russia just want to
finish picking the bones clean because
you know they have all that gas you know
all that cold war brainwash
yeah yeah man it's uh coming to roost so
it's crazy I'm looking at some of the
oligarchs on I just went to Wikipedia
Russian August we have Arcadia
ruttenberg Kennedy Tim uh timchenko
Alisha usmanov are these names ringing
about Peter Aven Mikhail procaro Oleg
deripaska there's nine of them
Alec elec perov Vladimir potanin and
Roman Abramovich he's probably the most
famous name-wise Roman Obama fish I've
heard what's what's crazy is the uh cost
of property in Ukraine because there's
no way the average Ukrainian can own
property
unless you're a coder
so I you know I know people I mentioned
it my friends were Ukrainian and they'll
say that like the average salary is like
400 bucks a month or something like that
and if you want to buy property the
prices are comparable to a property in
the United States it's like three
hundred thousand dollars to buy a studio
apartment in the city or something like
that and if you're making 400 bucks a
month you will never buy that but if
you're a developer or coder you're
making 150k per year U.S while living in
Ukraine you're living like a king you're
over there so what ends up happening is
the way they described it to me the
property is all owned by oligarchs and
everyone else has to rent from them and
they you can buy it it's for sale but
only the wealthiest people and
foreigners come and actually buy up the
property ukrainians struggle with it so
they own nothing but do they like it
you know it's a pretty chill place they
got cabbage and uh you can get cabbage
and beef and stuff like that I I when I
was in Kiev I was at the mydan square it
it was awesome it was a blast it was it
was it's a cool place so it really sucks
what's been what's been going on to be
completely honest going to little food
buffets they had I remember when I was
there
we were they had like a music there's a
TV playing with music music on it and
then uh Paris Hilton came on music video
and then I was like you guys get Paris
Hilton here my friend was like of course
we get all the American celebrities and
I'm like no no no no no you don't
understand Paris Hilton music doesn't
exist in the United States like we don't
listen to it and you guys do and that's
kind of funny to me I don't know I was
thinking about this Invasion and where
there's a lot of like Kickback now from
my friends that I guess you consider
more liberal they're like Ukraine is
Ukraine we're not we don't want Ukraine
to give up anything Russians should not
be invading get out we will will send
American troops to die to keep up and
I'm like where was your voice when the
United States invaded Iraq we're still
invading Iraq The Invasion doesn't stop
the day after it starts if we're still
at Presence there we've we're invading
in the moment where's your why aren't
you speaking out against what you can
actually control
a lot of them are two yeah a lot of them
are too young and just
if I can be crass too stupid to even
understand that you know people don't
see the whole bigger picture honestly
you know Ian mentioned we were living in
ignorance and someone super chatted
saying uh this is a Christopher Mar
saying Ian living in Haze of ignorance
is called living the dream but I think
what ends up happening is
you get a generation that raises their
kids in ignorance
then when they pass on the World to
those kids that's what you get
you get the bidens you get people being
like vosh when he came on the show and
I'm like what isn't isn't the corruption
of the Biden family from when he was VP
like a concern to you and he's like oh I
don't know anything about it I was a
little kid I was in high school when
that happened I didn't pay attention and
I'm like oh so like the bad guy
runs for office 10 years later and
you're just like I just heard of this
guy you know you're like uh-huh there's
a lot of bad guys you gotta look into
who they are yeah I think that's what
you know I can't say the rnt isn't
guilty of this but definitely DNC like
that's why they like young voters
because it's like a a blank slate yeah
yeah I would say the DNC like that's why
they often push these guys but I think
the RNC too I think all political
parties operate this way but I think any
time you get this new class of 18 year
olds who have the right to vote they
don't remember 30 years of political
history and especially it's even ones
who are super politically engaged they
just haven't had enough time to learn
everything and all the nuances and why
this Senator doesn't get along with that
one and this deal you know you can only
know so much when you're young but
getting them getting anyone to support
your ideology especially when you buy in
with like sort of the name brand I think
I think of a lot of modern politics like
rooting for sports teams you know like
you don't know why your family supports
this team you just do uh I I think that
is something that some political parties
take in stride you know they don't have
to explain the sins of people they're
now electing to president things that
they did when they were Senators mean
nothing to people who are new voters
let's jump into this next story and it's
uh it's kind of changing the subject but
it goes in line with what we were
talking about we have this from
timcast.com prageru personality details
YouTube kids promoting lgbtq content
these videos are not child friendly and
YouTube is pushing them to indoctrinate
kids and it's worse than that this is
Aldo uh butazoni YouTube kids is
grooming children with lgbtq propaganda
although I think you actually need you
you buried the lead here and I mean it's
a lot due respect the real concern is
that at a certain point he so what Aldo
says is he signed up an account made for
9 to 12 year olds and then one of the
First videos that pops up recommends a
kid meets gender non-conforming person
I I'm not as concerned with just that
the issue is when it gets into the ideas
of consent and they're telling children
about consent and they start talking
about here we go consent is giving
permission to someone or something
why are they giving 9 and 12 year olds
consent lessons in a sexual context this
is what's alarming about what YouTube
kids is doing so you think it's just in
the schools and Ronda Santos has his
plan to get rid of diversity equity and
inclusion but everybody in this is is
five steps behind what's actually been
going on and going back to Elsa gate
people have been giving their kids
YouTube their kids are then they're like
YouTube kids it's good for you and then
you get some adult in a sexualized
context like drag saying let's talk
about what it means to consent and then
in this thread I think it's in this
thread you have billboard Chris we've
been on the show a guy telling him that
their goal is to decouple age and
consent quite literally saying he wants
12 year olds to be able to consent with
adults this is what they're pushing on
kids I'm not surprised by it but it's
got to be Insidious it can't be overt
they can't come out right now and just
say it it's got to be a slow creeping
malevolent force that goes under their
radar so when Mom and Dad are busy with
work and they hand the iPad to the kid
and sign up for YouTube kids because
YouTube kids is safe what does YouTube
kids say come here little boy come into
a sexualized context where we can tell
you about consent that's exactly what
they're doing the internet and like
television is like inviting a stranger
into your home to babysit your children
like if you wouldn't pick some random
person off the street you cannot cannot
trust anything that comes from the
internet cable TV like it is written by
someone you don't know for a company
that you don't know what their values
are like even if you pick one video the
YouTube algorithm immediately serves up
another video like there's no way for
you to know for sure what's gonna happen
and that's why again I can't help but
think it's like inviting just a random
person you met at the grocery store to
come watch your kids for two hours and I
get it like it's hard to be a parent
you've got a lot of stuff going on
sometimes you need a break you need to
like have a way to engage your children
that you don't need to eat their present
for but like what if TV is not it sir
what if I told you that the YouTube kids
app was promoting child strippers to
your nine of 12 year olds well that's in
the thread meet Desmond is amazing now
of course his family is quite litigious
but there's a video of him dancing on
stage for money at an adult gay bar that
is the same thing as go go dancing
why is a child doing this and why are
they promoting this to other children
well I'm degradation of society to take
well that's for that's for sure is that
people are over overly sexualized
children will become overly sexualized
adults and think it's normal or okay out
of their own guilt like hey it's not so
bad what happened to me so you know it's
just something so bad terrifying and sad
yeah it really is cycle of abuse but
it's crazy because it also plays into
what we've been talking about about the
erosion of community again when people
are so into sex when they're so into
themselves and their own genders like
they're not paying attention to what's
going on they don't know about the local
school Border City elections they don't
know about any of this stuff all they
know is just you know it's about my
sexual identity my proclivities you know
indulging myself Nothing Else Matters
outside of just treating yourself and
and it just it takes your eyes down you
know basically and so it's uh you know
everything in life can be like into
sports so basically what typically
happens in football you know normally
quarterback he gets the ball he's
looking up at the field he's trying to
find a receiver to throw the ball to so
he's got to be aware but then pass rush
comes you know they start throwing stuff
in your face he takes his eyes down he
can't throw the ball he can't pay
attention you've suddenly stopped the
game from progressing he can no longer
progress the ball and that's what's
happening with Society we've taken our
eyes off of the prize which is advancing
Humanity technology everything else you
know creating families and now we put it
down on our genitals quite literally
looking up at the stars I think about
sending probes to Alpha Centauri it'll
take like 80 years for a probe to get
there can you imagine if we do that
today in 80 years we will have probes in
Alpha Centauri centers 80 years yeah
that's what I read anyway a couple weeks
ago that sounds like really fast yeah it
sounds super fast like within a lifetime
I'm going double check it but this was
like this is stuff we should be focusing
on aliens are watching and just going
like you know they had a lot going for
him when they went to that Moon and now
I don't know what they're like when
you're calling it might be a threat but
not So Much Anymore some rich alien
oligarch just lost all of his bet on
like this interdimensional betting app
and he's like God dang it Humanity you
screwed the pooch but it reminds me of
that expression like uh you can't see
beyond the nose on your face right like
if you can't stop but think about like
your own identity and your own sexual
pleasure and we're introducing that
earlier and earlier like how can you
expect anyone to spend time thinking
about like
the society around them or moral
philosophy or science or anything else
like everything is about the internal
and I think it's good to be in touch
with your emotions but you can't be so
dominated by your like personal
consuming thoughts that you are uh
devoid divorced from the world around
you but wait there's more because we got
to put a neat little bow on this this
ties into big Pharma because now when
you get all these kids exploring all of
these alternative sexualities now you
got the cisgender the trans pipeline so
they can now suddenly if they want to
explore let's get some Peabody blockers
let's get some gender affirming care the
next thing you know again that's where
social media comes in you know we're
right here at the whole dead internet
Theory they start getting engagement
from other people in that Community they
start flooding them and love bombing
them and so now they get addicted to
that then next you know they take it
further boom now you're done fully trans
the kid from YouTube kids and you know
that's that's omitting a lot of steps
but it's basically how it happens let's
talk about that internet Theory right if
uh if people aren't on the Internet it's
all Bots then where are the people are
they just not using the internet never
did man they're testing grass touching
all kind of the grass I think there are
tons of people who are not as engaged
like we talk about this a little bit but
like for your job for all of us like
being connected to the internet being on
Twitter stuff like that like it is part
of a professional Hazard like you need
to have the information but if you are
like an electrician who gets up really
early and works on jobs and comes back
and you hang out with your family like
you don't really have the time to just
scroll on your phone endlessly and keep
up with who's mad at who on Twitter I
mean I think that there's just a life
outside the other part is like some
people actively choose not to be online
right they choose not to have
televisions in their home they choose
not to uh sign their kids up for you
know Instagram or whatever else like
that you can be disengaged and you've
talked about this a little bit and like
there are alternative platforms right
like I know some parents who want to
share kids of photos of their kids but
out of privacy concerns they use they
don't use Facebook they use something
more private like there are people who
don't rely on the rest of the world for
entertainment and for us professional
content and I think that's healthier
it's just hard because I mean all of us
need it like this is our job yeah I
think about what if the power went out
that crosses my mind at least every week
I'm like what would my life become if we
had no electricity I mean part of me is
just like secretly in the back of my
mind saying like please do it do it yes
yes because I got a van that can
generate its own power and I'll be down
by that River Just Fishing yeah and just
kicking the feet some straw in the mouth
and just cast a line and forget about
all well I think of like all the
reporters who like had to go sit in
really boring Town Hall meetings to like
get the information then they had to
call people on the phone and talk to
them constantly like journalists still
do that from time to time but like we
are used to getting things much faster
because we have the internet nowadays
they just read tweets and report on
tweets like literally MSN journals I
don't know what they do all they do is
literally just write articles based on
what oh the this world reacts to this
this world reacts then they just oh
probably tweet Jim how many times some
news outlets picked up one of my fake
tweets and ran it as fact no for real
like I there's just uh how about when I
said the queen should be impeached so I
can I can't remember exactly what
happened but I said impeach Queen
Elizabeth and then m-e-a-ww.com wrote an
article saying you know podcaster Tim
Poole calls for you know Queen Elizabeth
to be impeached and I was just like holy
crap when that started it was hilarious
the indication of the rupturing of that
form of media is when they just started
quoting Twitter yeah it was like 2013.
imagine this journalists like for the
New York Times walking into the middle
of you know the Lower East Side and
there's a guy outside just like rocking
back and forth oh impeached Queen
Elizabeth
impeach sir what was your name what was
your name Bill Smith let's run it and
then goes back to their time and says
front page Bill Smith calls for
impeachment of Queen Elizabeth and then
they're like hey look he's a nobody but
people are going to see the story and
they're going to be like wow and P I
wonder who this guy is yeah that's what
they're doing Bill Smith I hate that guy
God damn it
oh God it's so funny though because yeah
you you sort of think about this and
then this goes into AI like AI is
literally getting all the data off of
all the crazy stuff that gets all the
clicks and then it just incentivizes
people to write even crazier articles
which causes people to tweet crazier
stuff bro and then people get in trouble
for like interacting the streets too
like we'd be on we've moved Beyond just
like people writing stuff like it's like
oh Ian Crossman Crossing like the
impeached Queen Elizabeth tweet so he is
supportive of this movement like it's
like you know what I mean it just
becomes this sort of hysterical culture
off of something you wrote as a joke or
maybe you feel that way maybe you can't
impeach the queen I know it's ridiculous
there have been several times where I've
tweeted something that is intended to to
make neither point so it's like a meant
to highlight just the circumstance like
I called the MSNBC Yasmin vesuvian story
about how she got the cold and got
myocarditis and I said I called it
anti-vaxx propaganda because what she
had a cold for three months clearly they
were making a segment that was going to
trigger anti-vaxxers and make them think
this was like I'm not and I tend to make
any point other than this is the
narrative this is like
just highlighting this thing basically
but they will take it and be like Tim
Poole is dead serious and thinks MSNBC
does these things and I'm like and part
of their story is also look how many
people are listening to person to this
guy look how many people are listening
to that they don't point it out they're
not like it got 80 000 repeats but they
don't really report on stuff until it
gets to a certain level of people
listening and then they're like we have
to take it seriously but we don't really
know how to accelerate writing a story
about it at this point at this point
guys we just accelerated as fast as we
can man just the hot takes they write
hot stuff people go mad people go insane
in the loop and cyclists let me pull up
this tweet this is an awesome tweet this
is from clay Travis He says lots of
athletes are finally catching on that
left-wing Sports media ask them
political questions so the left-wing
Sports media members can write their own
left-wing political opinions here's
Azarenka calling that out I don't know
if we can play like if it's it's a it's
a longer video you guys want us to do
here we go listen about it like talk
about it I I I don't know what's what's
the goal here
that is continuously brought up and this
incidence that in my opinion have
nothing to do with players
but somehow you keep dragging players
into it
so
what's the goal here
I think you should ask yourself that
question not me
sorry just did a clip on that though
does it frustrate you that
um you know particularly last month for
example it was a clear sort of
pro-russian demonstration happening
within the grounds of the tournament
that these people are coming and using
the Australian Open as a platform for
for these kind of demonstrations
does that frustrate you
[Music]
I
know whatever the answer I'm going to
give it to you right now it's going to
be turned whichever way you want to turn
it to
so
does it bother me what bothers me is
um
There's real things that's going on in
the world
and I don't know are you a politician
are you are you covering politics
yes and I'm a sports and I'm an athlete
and you should pause real quick I'm a
sports journalist he goes yes I'm an
athlete asking me about things that
maybe somebody says are in my control
but I don't believe that
so I don't know what you want me to
answer so anyway here's here's what I
love about this for one obviously these
athletes are like okay at this point
what are you asking about we had that
with um what's the name Ivan provorov
the the hockey players the Flyers Flyers
who was just like look I'll answer any
question about sports and then someone
asks them about like gay rights and he's
like what did I just say so here's the
thing
dead internet Theory we're talking about
Twitter being dead engagement is way
down for whatever reason and I don't
mean dead isn't the platform's broken I
just mean like no one seems to be using
it now we've got dead internet Theory
the idea that since like 2016 no one's
really used the internet and now you
have stories like this what you what you
see from this
Sports journalists have literally
nothing to write about so they go to uh
you know what would you say Malcolm your
your principal career is like what's
your what's your what's your main career
clinical research so um I'm I'm curious
uh when when cooking eggs in the morning
do you agree with Chef Andrew gruel on
adding vinegar afterwards and mixing it
in
um are there peer-reviewed studies I
don't know what this question has to do
with anything other than I can then go
out and be like you know clinical
researcher says no vinegar on eggs and
it makes it sound like there's a
scientific basis it makes a fake story
and then they can go I gotta scoop a guy
said a thing that's what the media is
today for the most part
ah man that is that's scary people
because people still take it seriously
that's the problem is that you know you
were just saying it you know
are people online like that do people
see this happening and you know in real
life people still take journalists
seriously that's what really freaks me
out because you know they're getting
their information from these people who
are basically like scraping the bottom
of the barrel and sitting up anybody got
scoop who's got the scoop who's got and
they literally write nonsense to which
people export to the real world yeah and
this is what I always said was that you
know back in the day they always said
Twitter's not real life I'm like yeah
it's not real life because it's got real
life implications like people literally
use Twitter to Source what they're going
to take out to the other people and talk
about around the water cooler or you
know to write articles about well and
like for this in accident like first off
that athletes Belarusian I just looked
it up so are they trying to trap her
into being representative yeah and then
also for this journalist like I'm so
glad she's like are you a politician
she's like I'm a sports journalist like
is this Sports journalist like here's my
chance to get launched into the
political on the political beat so I get
more money or I can raise my profile
because I had this good moment like it's
just such a weird way to operate and
especially since I know there are people
who would love to cover Sports
journalism at this level to go to the
Australian Open and interview these
people because they love the sport not
because they are trying to make some
political point to further their career
like if you're gonna further career on
Sports journalism ask her about
preparing for this match ask her about
something relevant don't make her a
poster child so you can sort of
transition into the political beat for
your publication
I feel like the whole like writing down
what the guy said is kind of like 1994
journalism style like you can just watch
the video of what she said I don't need
to hear someone write a story about what
she said when I can listen to her say it
or I don't need to hear someone write
down she hit the she hit the ball three
feet farther than the other girl who hit
the ball I'm like I can watch the show I
don't need that anymore I've been in
that video I can watch it 24 7. it's on
demand I I gotta be honest man it is it
is people often ask how do you do this
job watching all the stuff reading all
this stuff every day and I'm like you
know it does get really hard sometimes I
was uh I mentioned that we were hanging
out at the casino because we like to go
there now I started playing Holdem last
week some played like five times now
it's fun I love that game gotta learn
how to play it though and uh that's
funny anyway the the dealer was like I
hate politics I don't want to talk about
it it's too it's too awful and I'm like
I totally get that because what's what
what this country is devolving into is
our politicians are corrupt everybody
knows it Congress is corrupt everybody
knows it have you guys ever heard that
song Everybody Knows you know who who's
the guy who's sang that song Everybody
Hurts is REM and I don't know everybody
everybody knows I am no the people in
the chat are gonna know what I'm talking
about and I said that line like
everybody knows the fight is fixed the
poor standard Cohen yeah Leonard Cohen
there you go the poor stay poor the rich
uh get rich that's just how it goes
everyone knows that dice were loaded it
was Leonard Cohen and Sharon Robinson
wrote it together every everybody knows
and it's been that way for when was that
song written 1988 1988 yeah yeah man I
was two years old when people were
talking about how the system is
completely broken and I grow up and it's
only gotten worse well it seems like
that it's become more apparent but I
think that we have but let's control
citizens now than we used to I agree
with that I agree there's an opportunity
for success I I agree there's an
opportunity for the Phoenix to Rise From
the Ashes but I am not someone who just
looks around and says everything seems
worse than it was when I was a kid I'm
someone who decided to start asking
older people and so whenever I would
whenever I go out in the past several
months past year or so like the most
recent thing we went to the Antique shop
there's a guy and he's in his mid-60
season I said is it have you ever seen
it in your life this bad never never in
terms of the violence in terms of the in
terms of the corruption the tribalism
the bifurcation all of these issues the
economy and I'm just like I'm I'm look
I'm 36 in about a month and a week I'm
gonna be 37 and I can tell you that in
my life it seems like things are way
worse even like the economic crisis oh
wait to Me Maybe I was just too young
and I wasn't experiencing it no I wasn't
that bad oh it wasn't that bad unless
you had a lot of money we are with like
the lockdown nothing like it was a war
two years forced medication people not
be able to leave their homes people
dying in the world economic Forum
talking about the great reset I mean
this is like dude we've literally just
went from having people like become
millionaires overnight for selling means
mean stunks basically and you know and
now again now we're sitting up here
having these same people losing all that
money and trying to to re-enter into the
work like it's bad Joe Biden gave like
the authority of the American Military
to Vladimir zinc what the hell is going
on as our president in our in our lives
like and he just hand it over Carlos to
this guy yeah or not not literally but
like just so much money and tanks and
like you do what you need to do to
defend
something that's an escape amorphous I
want to talk before we move on too far
from this I want to talk about consent
which was part of this original story I
don't know if we will tap it off but
like part of what these these people
were like getting young kids to come on
and this is part of like social
degradation and things like that trying
to get 12 year olds to consent I'm
thinking genetic age and solar age are
different you can have an 85 year old
body that's been around the Sun 85 times
because you heal your body so much it
looks like it's 40 years old it feels it
essentially is a 40 year old body but
you've been 85 years so you can see like
just just because you've been on Earth
18 times around the sun doesn't mean
that you're more or less genetically
evolved we might have 12 year olds that
are that are more mature than in in 150
years than 25 year olds are today like
we may end up becoming so I can see that
but prepare for that crazy argument to
come out when they argue for for uh
grooming 12 year olds and stuff is that
it's not the same that's literally what
the guy said yeah okay good what the
pedo guy based on logic but it's not
based in reason the other thing is uh
when you get someone to consent under
duress it's not a real form of consent
if they don't understand what they're
consenting to they're not really
consenting legally right so a child well
it's capacity they have no capacity to
consent then you legally cannot you know
sign a contract or that person and if
you have a gun to their head and may say
say you like it I like it see he said he
like no you can't do that legal that's
not a legal admission I'll tell you when
it goes too far when we start doing
informed consent forms or research
studies for Pediatric studies where kids
no longer need a parent Guardian because
up until the age of 18 pediatric studies
and this is you know agreed upon by
everybody ever since declaration
helensky and all of these other things
and uh the Belmont reports that kids
have to have a guardian that has
capacity to sign that so when they start
you know conducting research studies and
you know God forbid you know your kid
gets enrolled in a study or something
and they didn't have to have you sign it
that's when you know you've gone too far
have you seen that no no and better you
can't that's ethical violation you can't
conduct research that way but it is I
mean at that point yeah that's when you
know uh and I wonder if that'll be
introduced more gradually you know you
have uh questionnaires your kids can
fill out school without they're
Anonymous it doesn't matter and then you
slowly ramp it up I mean I think
I think the issue for me with all of
this is like why does your 12 year 12
year old need to know about consent like
are you teaching them about consent
before teaching them about safety right
like they should know by 12 that it's
inappropriate for adults to approach
them and talk about these things right
they're saying the opposite they're
saying exactly like it's weird that
they're like well before anything let's
make sure you understand consent and
they might guys it as safety right when
you're older maybe you'll need to know
this but like really it's it's prepping
it's it's I know of course we'll see
this but grooming if the kid thinks that
they know and Society is telling them
that they know then what do they know
other than that they know yeah and like
what are kids famous for for being like
I know everything I know better than
anyone ever at all time because that's
just part of growing up right so if
you're like well I'm talking about
content and they say they know and
they're 12 or 13 like it just creeps me
out I don't know the only time that
Kamala Harris has ever said something
that was ever correct was that one video
where she said kids are really dumb and
they're gonna do dumb things but then
her party now wants them to vote and now
wants them to affirm to Medical
Treatments and you know uh sexual
relations so
I don't know I wanna I wanna talk about
uh Mr Beast and Hassan because we
had the story the other day we didn't
get into Mr Beast cured I think it was a
thousand people's cataract blindness
yeah with uh surgery and uh Hassan
got a bunch of what is this 24.8 million
views are you kidding holy crap look at
this that's on Hassan's one so this
tweak at 24.8 million views the video
was played 6.8 million times
and it says twitch streamer Hassan
explained why he was filled with rage
from watching Mr BEAST's newest video
where he cures a thousand people's uh
blindness so let's play this it's only
45 seconds long and uh I I think this is
an important point
[Music]
you watch this video go oh how how cute
and how nice I watched the video and I'm
filled with rage
along with you that we shut off access
to a 10 minute procedure because we pay
walled it and decided that like some
people just simply can't get it
it is so insanely frustrating that it
like it's up to like one YouTube guy to
like decide to make content out of it
that like is it people who are too poor
can't just see that's insane
anyway sorry it's just like a deeply
deeply frustrating concept he's 80 right
we didn't we didn't cut off access to
cataract search it just costs money and
he is right though that it's up to some
YouTube guy to make content out of it to
give these people the surgery they need
but you know what a lot of people are
ragging on them uh saying like he just
discovered what charity is and things
like that and I'm like as long as we are
giving a hundred billion dollars to
Ukraine I'm with this guy that hundred
billion dollars could be used to cure
blindness of American citizens who are
living in America in a country that
we're supposed like that is US literally
us so well I don't agree with him on
like it's paywall and we should just do
it it's like well look you got to pay a
guy to do it you know he's got to become
you gotta cover his his costs and
everything he's gotta get incentivize
him and slay them but how much money do
we send to Ukraine 108 billion dollars
so how much money this got 10 10
000 or 10 million dollars for uh if that
how much you think it costs for uh this
surgery to cure cataracts
10 grand is a good guess I'm checking it
out now so we're talking 10 million
dollars yeah just 10 10 million bucks
plus maybe a little bit more if he's
housing them or flying them out or
whatever but like right bringing them in
but maybe it's not 10 grand for this
surgery maybe it's four or five yeah and
I'm just sitting here thinking like well
you know I don't think we should just
take people's buying power through
taxation or through printing of money to
then give someone else some kind of
medical treatment so I probably disagree
with Hassan on that one but look if if
if we're in a country that's sending all
this money overseas for like gender
studies programs imagine if instead of
Pakistani gender status programs we were
like we're gonna we're gonna cure about
people's blindness reinvest so I got I
gotta agree it's kind of annoying that
sometime YouTube got to make content out
of it for the people to actually get the
treatment they need meanwhile they don't
fix our streets they don't fix our
bridges
um here's what I'm saying I'm not
necessarily saying that we should have
taxation to fund this infrastructure or
No Deal I'm saying so long as they're
taking all of our money let's compromise
and be like spend it on us fix our
bridges fix our roads get create create
jobs and construction that can restore
our infrastructure secure our borders
bring bring manufacturing plants back
here instead it's war in Ukraine a
border country in which we are not on a
border of and then our people are blind
and a YouTube guys got to clear gotta
clip their eyes he also gave people 50
Grand a bunch of them and one guy he
gave a new Tesla because he had never
been able to drive I saw this the video
is great you guys should watch it we
haven't seen it and he's like when I get
my eyes fixed I'm gonna get a car and
drive like that was his dream and Miss
Jimmy Mr Beast Jimmy Davidson I think
it's Jimmy Davis Donaldson Donaldson
Jimmy Donaldson I mean what a guy he
bought him a Tesla he's like crazy and
here's your Tesla pop culture covered
this today pop culture crisis uh and
they the Hassan thing or the the the Mr
Beast uh covers this because a bunch of
people on Twitter were like well he's
the Antichrist like who is he to cure
blindness you're gonna be like what like
give this guy a break like I I
understand the objection that he has and
I totally agree with you like if we're
spending billions of dollars on Ukraine
it's hard not to be an American citizen
and be like we have problems that if
you're going to spend this money you
should spend it domestically but I also
think like we shouldn't at all make this
uh Mr B's fault right like he tried to
do a nice thing he has a lot of money
and he's trying to help people like and
don't frame it as Jimmy cured their
blindness the guy the people cured their
own blindness with the help of medical
technology that Jimmy sponsored that's
the story he didn't he wasn't like Jesus
hands on people which he probably could
have done but he made a ton of money
because of it yeah oh yeah the revenue
on that is probably insane and just the
pr is priceless that's the that's the
thing nobody you know nobody ever thinks
about is a PR in charity is amazing and
you know there's no there's no better
return on investment when it comes to
advertising what
I was talking about this earlier imagine
if imagine if big corporations did
things like this for marketing their
whole thing was we got a 50 million
marketing budget this month I know let's
do the most good possible because it'll
generate attention imagine if Pepsi was
like I know how to get the best most
viral look at this remember the
commercial they did with that General
lady and she like walks with a cop and
hands him a Pepsi oh yeah think about
how much money they spend on that and
how it was just like yeah bad bad times
oh you want to honestly maybe not a flop
we remember it don't we yeah yeah
remember I guess you're right so maybe
they're like hey it was a success but
they spent a lot of money on commercials
that don't do anything I'll tell you
this right now Pepsi Coke you want you
look look at what Mr Beast did take your
marketing budget for the month and then
just like get a bunch of homeless people
a good meal cleaned up get them get them
help them find you know jobs help them
clip their lives and then you're gonna
get you're gonna get 50 million views
yeah you're gonna get 100 million views
I mean they would piss you guys off the
most is how much big Pharma agencies
probably get paid to make those generic
commercials where it's just like the
role of people just doing like basic
things like people skipping through
people skipping through a meadow people
going to a bar and they literally make
commercials for drugs like you see it
every single drug commercial just has
like people on random things like people
on a cruise ship and it's a lot of
scooters like going downhills and they
spend millions they spend Millions on
those ads just throwing it down the
drain and it's just like you sort of
think about how much money is wasted
yeah and how it that could actually be
used to pay it forward like this well
and I think about like uh the Ronald
McDonald house that was McDonald's big
initiative to like give people a place
to stay when your kids in the hospital
and like Wendy's has the Dave Thomas
foundation for adoption like there are
businesses that have philanthropic
efforts but and I'm not saying those two
are perfect examples but like often it's
like look at this thing that we're doing
as opposed to just doing the thing right
like yes Mr Beast made a video of this
yes he made money on the other day hand
like I I don't really follow his content
but like from what I know this is sort
of something he does he regularly tries
to uh help people out like if you had a
pharmaceutical company that just did a
nice thing instead of staging a photo op
like I guess I just don't trust them not
to sort of cheapen the effect right it's
about money and you know Counterpoint to
what you guys are saying you know how
about you know we invest in you know
doing these things you know if you start
making a big deal about you know like
giving away Medical Treatments and stuff
and you're a company that does that
medical treatment which you know
logically that's what you'd be equipped
to give away who's going to buy your
product anymore because they can just
wait for you to give give it for free
like this is what happened in Africa
when we started you know doing all the
food drops you know agriculture stopped
because again everybody was sort of
subsisting off of a lot of food drops
and so we sort of crippled them and
that's just human nature so yeah to a
degree I can see it but I can also see
you know when you start like
de-incentivizing the profit motive can
companies don't invest in you know
researching these treatments to come up
with new ones company you know we can we
can get Pfizer all the crap we want
about what they're doing at the same
time again
if one drug
and I I know this is going to sound
terrible but you know if them making
that money allows them to fund one drug
that can save somebody from a terminal
rare disease
you know it's kind of like well you know
it's evil but you know I kind of it's
It's but you want the other drug yeah
exactly yeah that's hard I mean it
reminds me of like um do you remember
Tom's Shoes
the like oh yeah yeah the economy in
those in those regions yeah but their
whole thing was like if you buy a pair
of shoes from us like you're spending
money but we're giving shoes away right
so like theoretically this sounds good
but there are of course consequences
they destroyed the economy in uh budget
African towns yeah because the Cobblers
all went out of work yeah and couldn't
buy anything everybody had free shoes
but it was you know the the guy who gets
the leather goes to The Cobbler the
cobbler and then makes the shoes and
then buys the leather all of a sudden no
one's buying leather anymore all of a
sudden the guy who who makes the shoes
can't make money now because you can't
make money he's not buying another guy
who gets the leather can't make money he
can't buy food neither can buy food
neither farmer is like I don't have any
money to get the tools I need to make
food and the economy just collapsed okay
each of these jobs is important because
they were all working for each other
making the machine work and then some
rich people came in and dumped a bunch
of shoes on them no I'm saying like you
know look people who are blind need
surgery I mean that's just giving jobs
to doctors I guess Jimmy actually
pointed out uh is this not even like a
great thing for capitalism in general to
put you know people that were before you
know broken or hurt back into the
workforce now they're healed they're
healthy they're ready to work so that's
a good thing for capitalism as well the
what he was doing technically I don't
know if you'd say it was a capitalist
thing or not it's irrelevant well I mean
everything's charitable right form of
charity for sure yeah but he's made a
ton of money off it with his YouTube ads
and he's doing it for money I mean he's
doing it because he loves people that's
the real reason but he knows that he can
make money off of Charity he started
with his mom when he paid off her
retirement that video went crazy like
he's talking to her and he's like
um he's like get this this will be a
good screenshot for the video mom and
then she's like oh my God Jimmy and he's
like thumbs up what is that wrong like
if you are doing something good but you
make money off it like you benefit
especially when you see I mean he is an
example of how great something like that
can become yeah he's like Oprah yeah you
can get much stuff away and he owns his
own everything let's just still do that
like just like do what because she's
retired now she like does her one
dramatic interview a year dang but I'm
pretty sure it was like the companies
would sponsor giving that stuff away she
was giving it away yeah that's the thing
about me he makes the money and he gives
it away yeah he said he's going to give
all his money away before he dies and
the problem
I I think that's a bad idea help him to
keep it so the the the I've thought
about this you know like where do you
invest and what charities do you support
and that's why we're working on the the
truth and media one because the issue is
I see these stories like bezos's wife
Mackenzie Bezos gives all that money to
wokeness so these people are like I'm
gonna do good I'm gonna give my money to
Black lives matter and then you're like
buying people mansions not really
solving the problem and I've had
experience with this nonprofit so I just
don't trust them yeah and a lot of
people like I'm gonna give my money away
and I'm like you're gonna flush down the
toilet it's like a Sam bankman freed and
his uh effective altruism and he's
talking about oh how can give them the
most causes that cause the most good and
then he just donates the Democratic
party because he believes that the
Democrats cause the most good he donated
people's money other people's money yeah
there we go that's the distinction right
and so again somebody he would say oh
that's like Robin Hood then but then you
know it's reverse Robin Hood he's still
chaotic evil you know we got it Robin
Hood we got we got to talk about this we
got to talk about these two stories
because we were talking earlier about
cultural Decay and societal Decay we
were talking about how um
was it Jack fasovic his neighborhood was
falling apart he's never gonna he hasn't
brought his kids back to see his
childhood home welcome to Milf Manor the
most repulsive exploitative sorted hate
to Hate show of all time where
blindfolded moms rubbed down shirtless
sons and TV finally hits Rock Bottom
this is uh MILF MILF Manor where moms go
and get a bunch of sons and they rub
them this is a 30 Rock joke on 30 Rock
they made MILF Island and they're
actually doing the show right now and
then I want to give a special shout out
to Dana White for power slap yeah Power
slap said to have its pay-per-view debut
in March with the League success this is
the show where people slap each other in
the face I take turns to do it and it's
like you gotta not get knocked down and
get back up or something this is
literally on my balls have you guys have
you guys seen Idiocracy an idiocracy
it's uh Luke Wilson you guys it's a
racist experiment for hibernation they
forget about him and it's funny it's
Mike Judge and then he wakes up 500
years in the future he goes to some
guy's house and then is there some is
there audio playing oh there is and then
uh yeah they're cheering for the slap
fight and then uh he's watching a show
called out my balls and it's literally a
guy who's just like he falls on the
fence he goes oh my balls and then like
someone throws a football and goes oh ow
my balls and that's the whole show and
then the guy's watching
this is that I'm sorry dude it's like
just jackass without the stunts pretty
much on my balls you see you see the
clips from this where people just they
go and they have seizures dude we gotta
we gotta play at least one the one where
the guy's face is huge on the left side
this one this guy so what they're doing
is they're standing with their arms
behind their back about two feet away
from each other across a table and they
are not allowed to guard or defend
that's the thing about boxing that's
legit is you can defend yourself you
can't defend yourself in the sport and
then they just take CTE they take yeah
Palm bone to the face over and over
until they fall down and go unconscious
look at this guy's face man this guy's
taking multiple shots to the side of the
head that's why his head looks like this
the thing is like and they have us as
well as like apparently it's a sport in
in Eastern Europe or something like that
where I don't know where it originated
no idea but they don't step into it they
just stand and slap it exactly and then
they take a full step and can turn their
whole body and get their whole weight
behind it and it's so much more Force
sometimes like yeah you can move and
they can use Palm strikes yes and that's
like I said it just it takes the sport
of slapping another person yeah it's not
a sport and then it just it just makes
it you see the Palm those Knockouts the
bone on the palm come in behind the jaw
and like pull it forward and some of the
strikes it is it is like I hope well I'm
afraid if someone's gonna get killed and
then it's going to be great news like
Dana's just laughing about it I don't
know I haven't talked to Dana about it
how do you win like you just they go
back and forth and they hit each other
until someone can't stand anymore
someone either bows out or gets knocked
down and is this like is this like with
UFC there's like weight classes right
like do you pair people up based on size
or is it random like no idea but I don't
think so there's a women's division I
saw two I haven't seen a guy in a woman
yet uh yeah well at least his powers
slap on YouTube does he actually do they
actually show yeah I'm sure they will
hear right in the beginning and they're
like highlighting these gruesome
knockouts
welcome to powers
from the fight
it's not really the sport that we're
about to be in we'll be up here with box
so you'll be up there no it won't this
is so dumb and I'll be able to be a
Pioneer within this sport I've been
through a lot in my life growing up on
the streets so I deal with African
streets there ain't gonna be no chance
of me quitting
I was brought up in a quite rough area
so yeah I've had to look after myself a
few times I think that'll help in the
competition
I just grew up tough yeah you know so I
want somebody that thinks they have
something to come fuel all this rage and
all this pain in this hand because I
will put it in her face
I came out here to do one job and one
tromboli and that's to put on a
shows
I heard people that's what I do nobody
touched me I'm untouchable baby you
gonna remember my name
this is where we're going to separate
the men from the boys the hardest
hitters a lot of trash talking a lot of
energy from start to finish
I don't care who you are I gotta say I'm
a huge fan of Dana White the UFC I love
it all this show just is really
confusing
[Applause]
okay he's totally wound up
yes it's just knockout porn dude
knockout porn that's all it is yeah the
doctors come in there this guy's gonna
have a CTE this guy's gonna have a truck
hey now we are doing this for free on
World Star Hip-Hop yeah wait a minute
how is what I don't get it what is this
it's it's a it's a bastardization of
something that is already popular that
Dana Weiss yeah I was gonna say all of
this reminds me of UFC yeah just except
for the actual contact oh it's when they
get that the the Palm bone across the
cheek jaw it's like the word critical
yeah but look like in in UFC and MMA
people they fight they block they defend
they make mistakes it's like it's like
uh uh it's a sport it's a chess strategy
yeah this is stand still I'm gonna try
and hit you as hard as I can and you're
gonna get hit someone tweeted out what
is it next like see who can survive a
stabbing the best
eventually if you ever watch the show
How I Met Your Mother they had like a
slap bat right and like if you lose the
bet you like one character gets to hit
the other one as hard as you can like
whenever and it's like that cross UFC
like I don't I don't understand why this
would be fun also like are they gonna
try to do like the uh wrestling thing
where they're like oh these two have a
rivalry because he hit him really hard
in the face like I got it it's just
weird you guys ever played doorknob when
you were young someone farts and then
you punch him in the shoulder or
something no no until they touch it or
not exactly you yell doorknob and then
you're allowed to hit him in the arm
until they touch the doorknob or they
fart and say safety and you can't call
doorknob that's the game we get a bunch
of guys in a ring and they're all
standing around and then everyone's got
to eat a can of beans an hour before the
event and then you're standing there and
then as soon as someone hears it
everyone everyone yells doorknob and
then you'll hear the Guy Yell safety and
then like the timer will call and be
like it's good and they'll go Oh They'll
all start running and start wailing on
the guy trying to get to the doorknob
but the doorknob's on a string and it's
swinging back and forth
somebody pulls a card in like the
doorknob's in the Box you got to open
boxes
that would be more Artful than this yeah
honestly like there's got to be some
kind of skill component it can't just be
who can get the critical hit like
seriously how do you train for this it
goes first like do you train to fall
down or do you train to slap or like
because if you're trained as a member in
South Park when Cartman would be like
let's rochambeaufort I was like what is
that first I kick you in the balls yeah
then you kick me in the balls and
whoever's Still Standing wins yeah who
goes first and then he goes I'll go
first and then he kicks him and so like
if you're training in power slap I would
imagine you're training your sparring
partner they call it sparring isn't
going to try and break your face because
you're going into perform pretty soon so
there might I can't imagine that they're
going as full force so how can you
possibly prepare for something oh no
because then we thought we have hard
sparring too and you know some it
depends like you know if you're a light
Spar maybe you're just focusing on like
the technical maybe it's just the
fingers just tip but maybe if your
heart's born you know you like give them
some full Palm action you know you like
to get real deep in there on the I don't
know man and this is
this what we're reduced to like we're
having uh we're having philosophical
conversations American Gladiators was
was like agility who was that Bill Hicks
he react on American Gladiators he's
like here's 68 channels of it or
whatever it's like we made fun of it but
that they had padding and they had those
big Q-tip things and they were like
trying to knock each other in the foam
pit right at least that was fun and
silly and no one really got hurt
American Ninja Warrior I love American
Ninja Warrior right yeah that's
fascinating you know what I don't like
about American Ninja Warrior it's not
fair to women oh yeah the upper body
strength requirements that's not that
it's the the what is it called the
spider walk or whatever the
it's two walls and you have to jump into
it and put your hands if you're tall
with a with a large arm span no problem
but there are women who are really good
really fit with great upper body
strength and their hands just don't
reach and I'm like how are they supposed
to do it their hands don't reach that's
dumb but this gives them a chance to
have it to be Innovative and like figure
out how to get through it and then the
first one that does it we're like wow
she was so sideways yeah is that
sideways put her back like I don't care
I feel like yeah that's true and it's
it's fair to acknowledge it but like
it's a chance for her to really overcome
true uh I shouldn't say City I shouldn't
say unfair to women it's unfair to
people with smaller stature or shorter
arms but there tends to be the women
because I'm watching I watched one where
the woman she her fingers touch the edge
and just Falls and it's like she tried
like yeah well I'm like what are they
supposed to do if they like readjust the
wall so they're closer it's like
slightly unfair to all the other
competitors like that's what I liked
about American Ninja Warriors they just
sent anyone down that thing and like it
doesn't matter who you are and like some
people struggle on some things other
people struggle on other parts of the
course like it's fast fascinating to
watch because it just depends on I don't
know maybe we should make the doorknob
show
please
doorknob the cast Castle guys are
outside like yeah and then like the two
o's and the word door eyeballs like
looking in no it's it's got to be like
one on one and it's like two guys going
to a ring one hour after eating a can of
Bush's Baked Beans
like they're like they're waiting and
they have like boxing gloves yeah but
you can't strike the opponent until they
fart and you call doorknob or but if
they call safety you can't and then you
know that'd be great you know that's
that's where we're headed I'm waiting on
this this is this is actually going to
be gold but this is the next big thing
people hang out at bars and be like you
want to put on doorknob like you know me
and my I used to play that when I was a
kid I'm having a hard time saying this
but I want to talk about MILF Island
back to True culture yeah yeah back to
my what I understand MILF Manor is weird
what is it okay I have just read very
little about it but like it's a bunch of
women who you might consider cougars
like they're moms all of them have to be
and they go to I assume you would
consider them a cougar I'm not an expert
you go to like Mecca they were filming
in Mexico but one of the requirements is
that they bring one of their single Sons
so like their son is living with all
these guys they're sort of weirdly group
dating because as a culture we've
decided that's something we're into and
like therefore like I I saw one clip of
it and this one mom is like careful
ladies I might asleep with your son like
I just don't like it it's so creepy
so like if if your mom is single and you
have a brother who's also single they
could go on this show but your brother
will be living with all these guys who
are kind of trying to sleep with your
mom bro like imagine imagine that you're
going to school and you find out that
your mom is on this show and like you're
getting roasted in the class you're
getting roasted in the glass and you
have like one good clap back and they
say but your mom was on MILF Island like
what do you say about that like what do
you say back then you just hang around
and shame and then go to a different
school like I want to be like my mom ran
Mill filing
you would be like go mom at this stage
of my life yeah or you can be or like in
all seriousness you're gonna be like
yeah well at least you won all right how
do you win I don't know what's winning
this year off the island there's
something for everybody yeah I can't
believe this is so what they they bring
they each bring us on and then they pass
their sons around to others yeah that's
it I've never seen a full episode but
like it's like what were those things
called where uh the swinger parties they
would bring out they put all their keys
in a bowl yeah white parties I think
that's what it's called white parties or
put all your keys in a bowl and then
they mix them together when you're
leaving you grab it and white parties
might be Coke parties yeah probably
probably that this was yeah I almost
went to one of those swinger parties I
almost went to one with this girl in LA
and I just never did it's kind of weird
a little crazy
swingers this one seems particularly
weird because like what conversations
are you guys having where it's like come
on John please come on the show like
Mommy really needs to meet a younger man
it's like probably from the people from
the porn generation that saw porn when
they were kids they were raised when
they were 11 and 12 watched MILF porn
probably the producers of the show
watched MILF porn when they were in
there you know when they were I want to
be in that boardroom and I want to
figure out what those people were on man
because they they were on the good good
let's let's let's just switch something
a little bit more wholesome have you
guys seen professional tag yeah that's
fun it's like an obstacle course and
like one guy's got to get away from the
other guy and he's running around and
you know that's fun they're like jumping
through obstacles and swinging through
bars and the guy's just trying to touch
him that's fun yeah we gotta have a
professional Red Rover or something that
would be so cool I don't know how you
gotta have like the Tim cats variety and
like game show where like every time you
just come up with like a new game show
like every week we could totally do that
at the new studio because we have that
big building I'm thinking of a game
thought do you want to live were you I
don't even
on YouTube it's a skit so I don't know
if it's going to play for TV but we can
do it behind the scenes you know do you
want to live and it's like base it's a
joke about the Canadian assisted suicide
stuff where like people come in during
suicidal you're like well do you and
then you you get them all inspired but
then the skit would be like at the end
of the show like the family comes in
like so thank you so much I love my life
and at the end like yeah I just thought
about it but I still want to I still
want to kill myself I'm going through
with it you know yes what you do is so
um I watched this thing and said that
every person who jumped off the Golden
Gate Bridge and survived yeah I
regretted it said that they yeah they
regretted it they realized and then as
soon as they jumped the first thing they
thought was that all of life's problems
could be solved except having just
jumped off this bridge so that means
people who didn't make it were in regret
so you take people who are looking for a
maid and then you you make life flash
Before Their Eyes in a manner of
speaking and then they're also like I
love life you know it's like in a fight
club member and Fight Club when uh he he
Tyler Durden holds up the the liquor
store guy oh yeah and he's like Raymond
what is it K hassle what did you want to
be and you're like vegetarian he's like
and why aren't you too hard and then he
says something really awful that I'm not
gonna repeat because it's when I run you
know family friendly show and then he's
like I know where you live if you're not
on your way to becoming a vet I will
come to your house or whatever and then
he runs and then Edward Norton's like
why would you do that what's the point
and he's like tomorrow Raymond castles
breakfast will be the most delicious
meal he's ever tasted and it's yeah can
I go back to milk Manor for a second
sorry yeah please family friendly
something just crossed my mind
um they couldn't make this show in
Reverse it couldn't be like Dill like
dad's Island right like you're a single
dad but you have a single daughter and
you guys come to the island and then or
if it was called Date each other like
you couldn't identify as MILFs though
then it's okay but you know what I'm
saying like if it was dads and daughters
like creepy everyone would be creeped
out it was so weird the dads would get
angry with each other hopefully you got
to give it 10 years
it probably wouldn't do well if it was
called like young studs too if it was
focused on the young guys they were
gonna get laid with the older women that
might not play as as heartily as like
we're doing this for the ladies like
this is all about strengthening women in
our society yeah I just don't like this
at all that's weird also like
gamification of porn man yeah that's a
good way of putting it I just feel like
if it's creepy if you made it adult men
and younger girls like it should you
should also see it as creepy if it's
older women and younger men it's not
just Epstein's Island at that point no I
don't
I was talking about how we're going to
do like a a morning show that's news
kind of like the view but with sane
women because uh I we've had we've got
you know women who work here moms and
then other people who have asked like is
there is there some way there can be a
show that's like Mom's talking about
issues that matter to them in politics
and culture because the views certainly
ain't it and then I was like we could
totally do it we've got we've got a
bunch of uh uh people that come in and
out of the show who are friends of ours
that are guests that are our moms that
talk politics that are sane moderate to
slightly conservative or libertarian
even a little liberal sounds good
someone just super chatted uh scrubby
mcgruberson says please name the morning
Mom news show MILF cast IRL
I appreciate the Super Chat because that
was a good one that was a good one I
actually am really excited for the new
space and they're hard at work on it but
we can totally do fun little game show
things I'm down for that we should we
should we should totally do with cast
Castle have like weird contests yeah
hole in the wall I was a huge fan of
that game show yeah that's so cool
they'd be standing on like a moving
platform and the wall would be moving
towards them but there would be like a
cut out on the wall the body yeah they
have to make the same position and like
stand in the right spot or they get
pushed off the platform and it's so
funny they'll like turn at the last
minute they're like ah because they
realize like three feet off and they're
trying to modulate and yeah we should
think of weird stuff we can do like
that's that's not vulgar and just
disturbing mxc yeah no I mean what's
that you know we could do mxc like like
Red Rover contest or something you can't
really do a Red Rover because it's not
really a game and we close on the dude
hard and that game it was uh Tom I don't
remember his last name we could do I
hope you're okay Tom Pro Freeze tags for
35 years ago
yeah that'd be so fun yeah part of like
entertaining stuff is like
I think so many people who make
entertainment right now are like it has
to either be sexual or it has to be
super violent and actually like what's
entertaining is seeing people like try
hard you know what I mean like with uh
American Ninja Warrior like Pro freeze
tag like people are trying to accomplish
something and like we we like that we
root for people who are trying to like
achieve yeah you see somebody somebody
uh super chatted saying dilf this is uh
Heron gaming saying Delph Island would
be two shows in one it would become an
MMA show yeah
so how about dilf Island this actually
this would be a really great Scrat a
really great sketch where it's like 10
MMA fighters with 20 year old daughters
and they're all brought in I mean it's
just all the dudes
he's trying to talk to this girl but
also he's design his daughter and that
other guy who's talking to her like it'd
be terrifying that'd actually be a great
show but also like all the men would be
accused of being super creepy and like I
think that should apply to these women
who are like you're the same age as my
son great and they're rubbing their
chest like what it's ridiculous yeah
it's weird super weird we live in a
weird weird Society this is why I'm like
cultural Decay man look they're
rebooting King of the Hill really not
rebooting they're restarting it they're
doing New Seasons and like Brittany
Murphy who voiced luanne's not around
anymore and what Bobby Hill is going to
be the same little kid or something
they're uh they're uh doing us a new
Frazier
it's just everything I thought he
already got a spin-off Frasier it was a
spin-off of cheers and then now they're
doing another one and it's just like
they keep remaking things they're out of
ideas Netflix is buying canceled shows
and then restarting them it's like do we
have anything left as a society are
humans just stagnant and bored well I
think they also don't want to take the
risk right like if you put a new show
out there then you are like opening
yourself up to cancel if I recycle old
material that at one point you were kind
of okay with I'm protecting myself a
little bit I don't like it uh but that's
why I have to watch all the Fast and
Furious movies because I was like very
anti-sequel and then I lost a bet on pop
culture have you seen any of them I'm up
to five I think I've seen one through
five but I have to get to nine before
the next one are you actually like
registering what's happening or you just
have them on I watch them and I take
notes so I can like report live it's the
most intense journalism I've ever done
yeah but like if you love car movies
yeah I get why you're into it I am not
into them so I don't tend to become very
invested in that like Fast and Furious
yeah cinematic
they could have done that in a different
movie with different characters and we
would be like whoa cars in space
the evolution of the movie series that
makes it so amazing it's like every
every movie they do they add something
to it and now that they're going on to
like what is it episode 10 or whatever
they already went to outer space I'm
ready to see Vin Diesel get super powers
yeah yes or a mech suit they should have
a villain shrinks down his car and goes
into a guy's body and then he has to
shrink down his car and chase him
through the veins they're like driving
on the veins they're like Fantastic
Voyage but you know the movie where the
guy goes He shrinks down except but like
you have a villain element to it in her
space he was like a white blood cell
that he went through the body I just
want over the 10th movie there's a Tesla
because that seems like it makes sense
to me Elon Musk has got to be in it like
I've never thought about cars so much in
my life I'll watch this franchise
and not free a bunch of slaves I will I
will personally Lobby any production
house or whoever's gonna fund this for
the next Fast and Furious movie Vin
Diesel and the crew are are driving
they're testing an experimental new car
with like a fusion you know plasma
reactor that explodes and the energy
hits all of them and they all get a
different superpower and then but one of
them turns bad and then like Doctor Doom
and then you know they're fighting and
like Vin Diesel is like super strong and
can jump really high and he like punches
the ground and the ground explodes and
all the other guy can shoot lightning
from his fingertips one guy gets like
because when they get knocked out of the
car like one guy gets the gasoline gets
on him and he gets lit on fire so he
gets like fire powers one guy's like
it's hit by the airbag so he becomes
like wind power or you know one guy's
like stuck under the tires so he gets
you know ground power yeah he turns into
a rubber man yeah he's rolling 20 on
that one you could have like
the with a bunch of the carbon
dioxide from the exhaust and he's like
breathing it in no he's taking them all
smoke yeah yeah so like there's like
black smoke coming off him when he walks
and he's like whatever happened to me
was a gift like and then just like no I
think it's blasted away and then
Michelle Rodriguez is like
it's just like not the same franchise at
all like it's not now
just make a different movie about this
no no you realize when you play games
like um software Inc you that you can
buy IPS so I could buy like an old movie
and then put that name on my movie that
has nothing to do with it and it will
just sell more tickets I get them I get
that there is just a cult following
there's something about this I'll never
totally follow ludicrous gets the
ability to like interface with machines
because that's his character he's like
The Tech Guy no that made me mad because
when I watch I think he smashed into the
car he's plugging in the USB right as
the the blast hits him
now yeah exactly and then all of a
sudden he's like I can see it is like
Neo and he goes like this and then like
the car moves and he's like
I am the cortex see that annoyed me he
was like I think it's like the fourth or
the fifth one I just watched it recently
like he was like this nice guy with an
afro and he waves the flags and he
collects the money but then they wanted
to bring him back so they're like we
gotta give you something to do he built
a spaceship you know how to unlock the
Vault I haven't seen that one yet don't
ruin it build the spaceship man he went
out of space with it I knew he had it in
him like I just don't get it like why
why is this the trajectory but I
realized that and think about think
about it I have a lot more to go like
whatever they're on 10 I think and then
but look they already the superpowers
are already in it I've talked about this
in Hobbs and Shaw which is a spin-off
Idris elba's a super soldier
cybernetically enhanced like bulletproof
or something I'm I'm totally down for
this and then in the 11th one they fight
Transformers then you bring Optimus
Prime and and and you know in it and
then it's you know it makes perfect
sense it writes itself you keep it going
into absurdity it would actually kill
because we're not in absurdity yet
imagine this imagine Optimus Prime has
got a blade through his chest and he's
like Dom you must stop get drawn and
then Megatron's like no in swings and
then Dom they both punch and there's
like little Dom and big Megatron their
fists are like
and that's the trailer I would spend 50
bucks to see that movie and you all
would too everybody knows it
and this is for my new family yeah
he has to mentioned family a bunch of
times always always I felt bad for him
when he was like on the run with his
sister and her new boyfriend who's also
a Fed who like got you convicted for a
car or whatever
old enemies
at all have you seen any of these just
Hobbs and Shaw oh okay let's just talk
about the Idris Elba let me tell you
you're missing a lot of DJs so none at
all well it makes me actually angry to
think about how they'll never make a fun
movie like that like think about think
think about the Spider-Man movie they
did was it no way home no which one
which one was it was it no way home
where uh Toby Maguire and Andrew
Garfield were in it was in it that's the
new one no way home and it was it was
awesome to see like the they rebooted
Spider-Man but they just twice so they
had to bring the other character to say
it's like a Multiverse and it was it was
fun and it was funny and it was cool to
see that they brought these other
characters back even though they're
completely different movie franchises
and the rumor is for uh the new so they
did Infinity War where all the Marvel
movies come together the rumor is
they're gonna do Secret Wars which is a
multiversal saga from Marvel so they're
apparently going to bring in Hugh
Jackman from the X-Men movies into the
MCU and have all these different
characters from different movies in one
Mo I think that's a fantastic idea yeah
I want to see Dom in Fast and Furious
swing a fist with Meg with Megatron and
they and they stop and like energy
bursts out and you know Optimus Prime is
there is it the actual Transformers they
get the rights I don't know who owns it
is it Universal don't they own both I'm
pretty sure that's just not appealing
yeah look up look up who owns both how
would you make it better
it totally is I know probably like a
woman who falls in love with a guy he's
a vampire or something no that's rude
I'd make it a Hallmarks movie
Optimus Prime is if it's a Christmas
small town a small town robot who runs
shirts as a truck driver and when Dom
brings his cousin back she's got a busy
business boyfriend who's the worst he's
the worst and she falls in love with
Optimus and realize she never left her
hometown and then down five Megatron
okay I'll think about it that's better
no I mean I guess for me this like I
also am not super into the MCU or like
the DC thing where it's like here's 87
characters and movies and like I just
feel like the plot gets lost but I
recognize that this is a personal like I
just am not into it well look don't
worry about all the characters because
eventually you're going to watch so much
much Fast and Furious that every
character is just going to be Dom on the
screen
they all are they're all versions of Dom
it's very weird oh really yeah also
things don't make sense and we're just
supposed to accept it yeah someone all
right we gotta go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kind of smash
the like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
become a member at timcast.com we're
gonna have a members only uncensored
show coming up for you just about an
hour and 10 minutes they go up on the
website front page every day about 11.
but let's read your super chats Tracer
says I am once again asking for channel
member emojis and perhaps even custom
colored beanie badges that's a that's a
good point let me write down emoji and
try to remember to get the crew on that
that's a good idea that's a good idea
tracer
yeah I was I've been playing OverWatch a
little bit every day little Heroes of
the Storm on my end oh I play later
tonight actually I'm not a fan of the TR
of Tracer in OverWatch I mean she's got
high DPS but it's just she's a good
assassin killer because she can get in
the back line she's faster than us she's
not in no in OverWatch I think just
Summer's better because Sombra can
stealth just walk right up aim at the
head and then warp out of there it just
it just makes a lot more sense than
Tracer tracer's you know rewind is like
a little chaotic anyway
says I respect the flax but I'm not
going to call myself Jam Frank or Eric
the rad seems cheap what is that
what I don't know you don't know what
that means oh damn Frank or Eric direct
oh historical fig I think I like
historical figures wow
yeah I follow now okay all right we got
Raymond g Stanley Jr he says Tim I dug
the 4 P.M I got to thinking about all
the small towns in PA with boarded up
windows down in Main Street and how
they'll never come back sad man I was
talking about how if you go to small
towns today you'll see the downtown Main
Street all the all like not everywhere
but a lot of these small towns there's
just nothing yeah like in Brunswick a
lot of these businesses there's just
nothing there anymore and it was re we
drove through recently and there was a
shop it's gone now and I was like what
happened to that shop that was there
like they're closing down Amazon's
taking over and so I'm just I always
tell people I was saying
look at that boarded up old building and
imagine what it must have been like when
it was first built and there's like a
young couple that just got married and
they bought their first house and
they're standing in front of it and
they're smiling and they're like we're
gonna make it work this is it and they
go in there and it's like 1950 something
and they're painting the walls and
they're just like this is going to be
our dream home and then it's like it's
like the movie up you know now it's all
broken up falling apart there's no one
left anymore so that's crazy I remember
I was in um I think I was in Ukraine
and I walked I saw this old dish like
just rusted piece of crap car and I
thought about how you know when that car
was first sold some dude who bought it
was like yes oh brand new 1968
Volkswagen and now it's just rusted out
rotting and it's someone's junker yeah
imagine crazy right all the all the good
feelings all the like you know when you
first buy that car like everything you
think you're gonna do with the car and
then just to see where it is now like
it's it's so disappointing it's almost
just tragic I I like buying like vintage
clothes and I think about that
especially the stuff that's like custom
tailored you're like oh this was like
someone's like big moment you know dress
or outfit like they wore it somewhere
important and now it's just something
I'm buying for like a dollar at an
estate sale depressing Max Reddick says
can you try to get David packman back on
he was just on valutainment and he seems
like one of those my brain broke because
of trump type of guy uh I've known David
Pacman for like 12 years and uh yeah we
should invite him out the thing is it's
hard to get excuse me people out who
host their own shows and I'm not gonna
like
I'm not going to be critical of of David
because he probably can't come on
because he literally does his own show
it's it's like hey cancel your show and
come on mine instead it's kind of a
weird thing to ask somebody and um
there's a legitimate reason why we just
don't Skype people in
it is not the same thing it's just
really not I don't know maybe I'm wrong
I just kind of feel that way and uh I
just I don't think internet
conversations are the same as actually
having someone in the room it's not
because it's digital a lot of it
literally uh if if two people try and
make a sound at the same time only one
of the voices can be registered as a one
the other one will be registered as a
zero and you'll hear mute so two people
can't like you and I can sing harmonies
and since we're it's an analog
conversation it's not gonna I don't
think it'll mess up I think we should do
it too we've also had good uh
we've had good response from like
streaming on one channel and then
flipping over to the other channel 20
minutes in you know I stream on David's
Channel and then uh yeah or both or
whatever but uh uh you know if you came
out I'd love to have him on but I really
would love to have Kyle Kolinski and I
think we're gonna we're gonna bring Kyle
on I think Kyle's great yeah he's
awesome I think I think you know we
disagree on some political issues but I
remember one of the first experiences I
had watching Kyle klinsky's content was
him defending Carl Benjamin and some
some leftists was attacking Carl on
calling white supremacist and Kyle was
like that's not true like you disagree
with Carl but he's not that guy and I'm
like well like he was being completely
honest and I was like I respect that I
like the name of this channel secular
talk so I imagine at some point he had
some sort of religious like Epiphany or
something whether it was to get away
from it or to go towards I'd love to
hear a story about that plus it makes
sense that I think he's getting married
to crystal ball and she is also very
similar like she's Progressive but you
know obviously her and uh soccer and get
either yeah like they have disagreeing
opinions but you know you can have a
conversation about what you disagree on
but you're having a real conversation so
that's why I like I like breaking points
you know formerly it was you know
Crystal and soccer were doing uh the
hills Rising yeah but they're good
people Crystal Kyle and friends I think
that's the name of the new show yeah but
I do think that they end up associating
with bad with a lot of bad faith people
and I suppose people could probably
argue that for us as well like some of
the people come on the show probably bad
faith I think my my issue was only like
dude we invite people on like we had the
krakensteins on you know we I'm props to
them for coming on yeah but a lot of
these these lefties won't do it and I
think it's because they're legit
grifters it's like you can't accuse like
they come out and they'll call us or
other people on the right grifters when
quite literally Ben Shapiro is like
please come on my show to have a
conversation and they're like no it's
like how is it grifting if he wants you
to go on his show and say literally
whatever you want yeah not so full of it
they're full of it man it's just uh it's
one of those situations where again if
you don't believe what you're saying if
you if you don't care about it enough to
at least have a bass Landing yeah you're
a grifter in the worst way now if you're
just making money from it then I mean
that's not bad like you know you're not
a grifter because yeah at least believe
it a little all right scrotes mcgoat
says Tim I can't help but notice that
nobody including you has mentioned the
Drone attacks on Iran over the weekend
well I don't really know what to add to
that conversation or what to say I mean
what do you guys think it's first I've
heard of it still a developing story
honestly but I mean you know for what we
know is Israel is involved and or at
least that's what they claimed and you
know right now it's got some
implications because you know Russia
those uh Shahed drones that they use to
basically you know put give give in the
dark came from Iran so
it there's still a lot of stuff coming
out about that so I don't I don't think
it's wise even you know render a
decision I tell people this all the time
tactical patience just literally do
nothing just wait Wrath of Paul says
last night's episode was one of the best
ever Matt Strickland is an American hero
it was very inspiring to hear his story
about how he won against tyranny I love
sticking it to the man yeah Matt
Strickland of Gore melts in Virginia
Google it look it up go head down there
they got amazing food 90s music it's a
gourmet Gourmet was at 90s music and
brew has something like that I don't
know something like that I'm getting the
name right now to remember it and he's
running for a state Senate in Virginia
so they they try to shut everybody down
over covid and he says look these rules
don't make sense they said put up
Plexiglas but he was like how big where
how like what if I put up one inch of
plexiglass and they're like yep that's
fine he's like but it doesn't make any
sense why are you making me do this
people can wear mat people have to wear
a mask when they walk in but they take
it off and they sit down what is that
what does that even do it makes no sense
so he said I'm not doing it they
eventually came after him
they they pulled his licenses and then
he said okay well I don't care I'm gonna
keep doing it then we all saw this viral
video where they raided his store and
took all his booze and this is under a
republican mind you Junkin and he still
said I'm not gonna do it he won
everything he won in court he won back
his booze he won back his licenses
because he just said no and he refused
to comply and you know the worst thing
about the story is he said that tons of
people hit him up saying what you did
was amazing and he says well why don't
you do it like oh no I well I can't do
that I don't want I don't get the health
department on me and it's like you you
cheer on the one guy who did but you
refuse to stand up with him that's
that's brutal man yeah I think his
example that you can emulate people like
Matt the amazing guy it's really hard to
do though man because they put they put
him in the pain box like you know they
really didn't make him put his hand in
the pain box and he just yeah that will
is not common that's the thing you don't
have people to have that willpower all
right Daniel Welch says I have history
of autoimmune pericarditis always
disclosed and accepted for health life
insurance recently denied life insurance
because of pericarditis I wonder what
changed recently very interesting
very interesting indeed yeah we didn't
we you know what let's let's talk about
the MSNBC host for the members only and
we can get we can go nuts on it yeah
you've got a lot of medical knowledge
that I think you bring to the table on
that yeah blood cells and yeah we were
talking a lot about this so we'll we'll
talk about that she's like I had a
common cold and it turned into
pericarditis and then a week later
turned into myocarditis and it's been a
month and a half and I still have a cold
and I'm just kind of like real quick do
people get colds for that long that is
is really rare typically if you're
immunocompromised something like that
could happen and you know again that's
what I was thinking I'm like when I get
a cold it's like three days I start I
wake up and I'm like oh I'm feeling a
little sick then the next day I'm like
oh I'm sneezing the next day I'm like
wow I'm feeling like I'm getting better
and then the next day it's just like I
don't know it's uh was it the rhinovirus
yeah it's actually a it's actually a
family of the coronavirus believe it or
not still uh you know the common cold I
was reading about it says it duplicates
at 93 degrees Fahrenheit which is the
temperature of your nose so if you have
snot in your nose and you're not blowing
it out that's where it's duplicating and
duplicating
keep that empty go in there that's why
it goes in your nose huh yeah it's a
great breeding ground for the rhinovirus
John written written off says I'm
digging Ian's jacket hell yeah dog yeah
all right what do we got here AK storms
there's a lot of people I follow that
did lock their accounts and their first
post asking if they are finally being
seen I I saw a bunch of people all of a
sudden all my retweets were gone all of
my quote tweets were broken and I'm just
like I can't like dude you just cut
yourself off from every post and it's
just it's a weird thing man it's a weird
thing how long do you think they'll stay
locked for I don't know is this a
lifestyle change permanently or a couple
weeks maybe thinking but look some
people people went public again people
are saying people are saying like oh
you're you're it's it's hyperbole to say
Twitter is dead and I'm like it's a it's
a figure of speech I'm not saying
Twitter broke I'm saying that if large
portions of high-profile personalities
have locked their accounts and no one
can see what they're posting and I can't
share their stuff anymore and they did
it because no one's getting engagement
come on man like it's dead yeah the
platform is dying
and and and and look it's uh Dave Rubin
did that thread where he said there the
code is is a of what I call the fractal
Rube Goldberg machine and they're trying
to fix the code but they pull one piece
out the whole thing starts breaking
apart it might just be they're gonna
rebuild it from the base up they said
yeah it might be that the site is under
intense anesthesia at the moment and is
unconscious Fully Alive and under in
going into surgery
yeah yeah then they're they're gonna
have to do that but I mean that's taking
the company private though that's
technically what that is because you're
rebuilding anyways he did that Elon did
that when he bought it yeah so it's been
under anesthesia
all right Jeffrey perine says I think
you would love the Book of Proverbs the
wisdom book it's series of limericks
about wisdom and the consequence of
rejecting it it seems similar to things
like Confucius written by Solomon yeah
interesting very wise book I used to
read that one actually a lot but God I
can't remember any of them it's just too
much good stuff that's why Patriot
American says Tim when your West
Virginia location finally opens we'll be
promoting the address so people can
submit applications to work there or
have you already received applications
for it we have like a couple
applications from people who met us at
uh events but once once the the location
is open and we say what it is you'll be
able to Google it and then everyone will
uh will come and so this is what I was
trying to say to people in the city like
look I think it's a coffee shop it's
gonna it's gonna sell coffee people are
gonna go there for their cup for
breakfast for breakfast and stuff but
we're gonna do events and we're gonna
invite you all out there so I'm like
this is going to bring people to the
area it's going to be good for everybody
so I think there's a lot of excitement
and you know uh there was an all ages
drag show nearby yeah and that that
actually got me close to canceling this
location saying like I don't want to be
in a town that would tolerate that would
advocate for this and and then I thought
actually the opposite we're going to
bring our influence into this town and
just be like we we don't do this here
like you can't abandon the territory yes
right like if you're in a Battleground
you don't just give up yeah and it's not
about like going out there and and
protesting it's about saying like look
you do that we're gonna do an event and
we're gonna say no and we're gonna have
games and drinks and we're gonna put on
you know what I'll do I'll put on a drag
show
big drag show biggest drag show and
we'll have uh food and and booze of
course that means 21 but only yeah no
kids no kids allowed and we I will make
it so that look I don't care if you have
a drag show that's that's great like
have fun be an adult do weird stuff do
fun stuff have a good time no kids this
is not for kids and so this influence we
can bring in can be more libertarian but
it can also be like hey bring your kids
here and that's what they were doing
yeah and that's that's just like it's
not appropriate man we're gonna do
Saturday morning cartoons we call it
bring in your kids hang out we'll do
catered breakfast you come in we'll
figure out whatever it costs everybody
gets eat pancakes eggs sausage bacon
maybe maybe well we gotta have pancakes
but I recommend people avoid the the
glutens and the sugars and all that
stuff almond flour yeah we could do or
or a mix it list at least like a like a
uh we had this almond flour that is
tapioca in it and it's it's really good
yeah if you've ever cooked with like
almond flour or even like coconut flour
dude yeah you can do some good stuff you
remove the carbs you add a little bit
more fiber which is good for the gut and
it's just it's just better for you but
then we'll put on approved cartoon shows
maybe like daily wires chip cello when
that comes out things that are gonna
instill kids with you know like I think
Justice League the the I thought that
was great a lot of important lessons
like Young Justice man I should have
canceled that show yeah static shock I
thought was actually a really great show
yes for teaching kids lessons yeah it
did that it was yeah it was it was good
it was like the kid got caught up in
gang violence then uh what is it like
the the big bang happened where all the
gas explode babies and they became
metahumans basically and so now you know
he's literally at school with like
School super powered School bullies and
he's just all the while coping and you
know kind of coming into eight yeah they
had the racist episode they had the the
homophobia episode where like his friend
is gay and his dad is intolerant but
they were like I thought it all worked I
thought it was all like relatively
libertarian so I'm like I think we can
we can we can make this work anyway
that's gonna be fun I'm super excited
for this Melissa wood says Malcolm rolls
at 20. BlackRock and zelenski just came
together to rebuild Ukraine have you
guys seen the video about what the goal
for Ukraine is a completely digitized
Society by 2030. yeah so what if
Conspiracy Theory what if the war is
part
of the world economic Forum great reset
and Putin is the faux villain and
they're they're damaging Ukraine on
purpose because you have to destroy
before you can rebuild
how do you radically transform something
to create what you want if there's a
layer already on top of it of a culture
in a society decimate it and then so
this is what happened with the NHS in in
the UK for instance how did you get
nationalized Healthcare in Europe World
War II yeah everything was just
destroyed and people had no choice you
had to give people Medical Care and so
it came from the government now it's
just a part of their system right
conspiracy theory I'm not saying it's
true I'm saying at the very least
whether whether that's true or not what
Russia is doing will result in a Recon
reconstruction that will be radically
different
very strange they're gonna have the best
internet no joke yeah it's gonna be
great because when they rebuild it
they're gonna reveal it with top tier
Tech and they're gonna have like gigabit
phones and stuff yeah you got the best
slave masters they're the most high-tech
well and they're over here where all the
resources in China's basically
bankrolling that whole entire region
right now so yeah cran yeah yeah well
Russia basically but they'll probably
get in on it because China likes to make
money that's literally what they do yeah
you can see what happened Rolanda too
all the internet and everything got so
good there now it's like the Singapore
of Africa wow yeah 5G baby yeah
let's grab some more grafty says uh that
jacket is nice Ian thanks crafty yeah a
lot of people are commenting on uh on
that jacket it's my blue uh what is this
velvet velvet yeah man that's awesome I
should know blue suede I was gonna call
it blue velvet
and looking smooth over there I was
about to say that is that's the 20
rolling jacket right yeah I got a
rolling jacket gold green and blue
so far Quantum strange quarks is a
hundred billion dollars would be enough
to give every homeless veteran 2.5
million dollars each
got to make sure that math is correct oh
God don't remind me of the one meme I
mean maybe how many homeless oh the the
Elon Musk purchasing Twitter meme where
people like purposely get the number and
the number of people that he could have
gave given 44 billion wrong remember
when that lady went on I think it was uh
MSNBC and she was like uh what did she
say there's a tweet and it's like Brian
Williams and he's like Michael Bloomberg
spent 500 million dollars on his
campaign there are 325 million Americans
he could have given everybody in America
a million dollars and had change left
over still be rich and she's like it's
crazy isn't it but it's true and it's
like he could have given everybody like
a dollar fifty these people don't know
what are you talking about you don't
understand Elon Musk bad no don't
question the math but a hundred billion
dollars
that is massive yeah that's a lot of
money 2.5 million just one percent of it
like you won't even miss it come on it's
gonna go anyways
Peter Watkins says Tim you advertise put
your money where your mouth is I mean I
I I I did to a certain degree right I
didn't go out and like cure a bunch of
blind people I could I think it'd be
great marketing if we made the same
video and we're like the Mr Beast
challenge spend your marketing budget
how about we do it how about we do a
response to Mr Beast just straight up
saying the best possible marketing ever
is is helping people and I guess the
issue is I don't think I haven't I don't
have nearly as much money as Mr Beast
does how many people can we can treat
maybe well we're helping buckle with
stem cells we could do that with cats we
could do it with people's animals we
could do like put it put a million
dollars into like just heal like 150
cats or something or 200 and 300 just go
to like a a local vet or a vet hospital
and pay off everyone's bills yeah if we
had a million dollars lying around or or
even like a because it's not that
expensive it's like what was the five
grand I think for the entire like eight
grand for the entire process we did that
for like 100 people or something that'd
be but it's not the people it's the cats
so it's seeing the emotion response from
the humans that are able to see again
that really sells the but then the
question is do you then make a video put
it on YouTube so you can make Revenue
off it and then continue this process
exactly and that that could potentially
be the thing right so we we spent I
think like half a million bucks on the
Times Square stuff throughout throughout
last year and this was over over like
four months so it's not like all at once
all at once is not possible but spread
out over time with Revenue coming in and
then we spend our excess on trying to do
something impactful I think we could
potentially do something like that maybe
in a few months after we generate enough
Revenue then we can spend it on
something you know Jimmy was already
pulling in Revenue I believe when he
started feeding it back into the system
so he was already self-generating but I
mean like I said it works it's an
investment
so it it uh works it's actually a pretty
nice investment but I mean have people
send in ideas you know and uh maybe like
every Everybody yeah every month like
draw an idea and have that person you
know come see the come see it in action
or something all right I guess I got to
read this one cage the mix says Tim
needs to stop putting black guests in
front of black dark colored backgrounds
I'm sure it's just a coincidence that it
happens every time there's one guest
seat and we have the sound proof of the
door because it's a bathroom and there's
three layers of sound proofing for
obvious reason so but you know yeah
that's a fair point it's it's so it's
just to check see if you're paying
attention because one day one moment I
could be here next moment I could just
ninja away you got to see me people are
pointing out the contrast like Hannah
Claire is very pale and
but like we just always put the guests
there so it has the brand behind him
which is nice for when the from the
clips come out you always remember what
show well I don't know it's just it's
just color and it's a problem it's
always been the guest see I think it
would be weirder if we were along
another black guests have to sit over
there yeah
right look I might start giving me
another eyebrow hold on now I saw the
last one yeah wait a minute you're too
dark you can't sit there like that
sounds awful that is like really I can't
see see but I left this would think that
that was Progressive so we have like
emails you've been like but please don't
wear black just wear a white shirt a red
shirt a colorful shirt no actually no to
be fair you know we would yell at Luke
all the time for wearing red yeah
because it it it the cameras go nuts
yeah it turns red or blue yeah it's like
you know if you guys wearing this crazy
crazy jacket yeah if you were like a
white shirt maybe you would have popped
on screen like I feel
I don't know you remember that
commercial where they did this diversity
camera thing where they're like our
cameras can actually take pictures of
black people oh yeah that was like the
marketing campaign oh my gosh oh
I remember now true yeah Jesus Christ
I mean I whatever man you know make
camera that works that's fine I got no
beef yeah as long as everyone
understands it's not me guys it's not my
fault
over there dog whistling in the corner
crispy cave says if you guys are
confused by slap fights you have to
check out in car MMA I've seen that I
think it's where they fight in a car
stop people
car Jiu Jitsu yeah you found it
submission grappling inside of a car
just go to a dangerous city like I don't
understand what we're making this at the
Muay Thai practitioner I already make
jokes about jujits you earn
practitioners but to see like them doing
trying to like get a Kimura in the
middle of a over over the dashboard
that's hilarious I'm looking at
lowkickmma.com and you see a dude like
jumping over the seat the dude in the
blue is trying to wrestle them do people
so like if you're in MMA if you like do
UFC fighters transition into this is
this a launch pad for like a different
career how does it what's the ecosystem
here typically you start training
getting out of gym and you know you
start amateur so you know you're taking
taking a few fights in like little small
amateur League some people they they go
to rap they start eating Street beefs if
you've ever watched Street beefs it is
addictive but then they go to like these
smaller leagues things like um you know
well you know we can go into Strike
Force but you know you got cage fighting
and stuff and they eventually just move
and they get signed to UFC it's kind of
like boxing but like if you're in UFC
now do you start fighting in the car
next no then you go to movies oh okay
all right I want to grab this uh this
last one uh what is this uh Arnold uh
our olfo Flores says hey Tim are you
willing to accept gold backs as currency
in your Cafe yes if we're legally
allowed to which I think we would be so
we actually have a bunch of them we have
a couple stacks of the the gold backs
that I got a while ago it is gold foil
one one thousandth of a troy ounce in a
you know bill and it's like laminated or
something it's like sealed I guess or
whatever and so it's a it's a gold bill
and I think they're value is around like
between two and five dollars depending
one percent of twenty one hundred
dollars out right standard boys so you
walk in and it's like someone says we
take a gold back I'd probably say sure
all right
I might honestly even accept your
partner to be honest like you come in
and you're like like a coffee's like
what do you got I have this really
really Nifty chain and like I'll take it
I can walk in and back I got an old bike
lock I'm like throwing the pile turn it
into it I'll start bartering for your
coffee yeah how did I say you want the
venti you gotta really got a Barger
there
wasn't like let's just pay you in
nickels because nickels are worth
something yeah you get a discount if you
buy if you spend nickels because nickels
are worth more than their metal than
they are in their currency yeah all
right everybody if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this YouTube channel share
this share with your friends because
that's what really helps take the URL
and post it everywhere
um we're bigger than CNN already that
was the news they they struggled to get
as many viewers we as we get and that's
kind of a crazy thought so that's kind
of funny too bad sorry CNN they get more
their YouTube clips get hundreds of
millions but like as a prime time show
live we we're actually uh beating them
in the key demo and I think we're nearly
beating them in all demographics too
like we have more we have we have more
key demo viewers almost almost more
Kingdom of yours than their total
viewership their key demo is 93 000.
yeah that's crazy and msnbc's is 69 000.
so anyway thank you all for supporting
our show for sharing and uh it's it's so
crazy to go out and have people be like
yo Tim big fan because it's remarkable
uh just to see how how far the show has
gone thanks uh how far it's come thanks
to all of you who support it share it
watch it so become a member at
timcast.com go to teamcast on go to
timcast.com click join us and then we're
going to put up on the front page you'll
see it uncensored members only show
that'll be up at 11 PM you can follow me
at timcast you can follow the show at
timcast IRL and you can follow at
timcast news for our field reports
Malcolm you want to shout anything out
yeah man all right I came here on a
mission guys
I cannot downplay the enormity of this
arfo you got the word of big Pharma
right
well we are taking on big meat and
currently big meat is Master we can't
grasp the girth of our opponents but I
am sponsored by Alpha jerky we're not
talking about Jacqueline's we're not
talking about Slim Jim we're talking
about Alpha drink this is real brisket
there we go sorry yeah this is a real
brisket jerky we've had some of that
yeah it's good but not super good yeah
salt and pepper don't taste me bro
brought it over oh man and it's legit
there's like what no preservative the
ingredients are beef salt pepper mm-hmm
honestly like I eat this the macros are
amazing I'm full this bag is almost gone
like I've literally said this whole bag
like when it was here like yeah it's
some of the best yeah yeah
use promo code flex and you can get 20
off your order so that's right guys I
got a promo code I came meaning business
so again this is real beef not that fake
uninspired beef not that AstroTurf beef
America beef America America is there
anything else you want to say you got a
Twitter account or something oh yeah oh
yeah I'm so focused on the The Jerky
look big meat we have got to wrestle big
meat back into his place but anyways
okay follow me guys at Malcolm
underscore Flex 48. on Twitter you can
also go to
www.flexorsuccess.com once again that is
www.flexyoursuccess.com
so what was that promo code again Flex
Flex Flex cool yeah I like the flex guys
oh look at that look at that this is for
me now for jerky right here this is the
mercury made muscle so go ahead guys
uh I'm Hannah Chloe brimlow I'm a writer
for timcast.com you should go to
timcast.com click on the read tab you
can see stuff from me from Shane Cashman
from Kiss car from Chris burpen
apparently all the Chris is uh and you
can follow me on Instagram at
hannahclar.b you can follow me on
Twitter at HC brimlow and you definitely
should follow Tim cast news at timcast
news on Twitter it's the best you can
get all your news there from us to you
thanks so much and you follow me at Ian
crossland.net if you'd like to I'm gonna
go do some air squats after the after
show I highly recommend if you guys have
not done those before epic core exercise
get the blood flow after five squats you
are into it you know so treat yourself
right do a little bit of exercise catch
you later
yeah that's good man and uh I am at
surge.com uh unfaxed and uh unlocked on
Twitter guys uh you guys should stay
unlocked don't lock yourself it's just
ridiculous making an echo chamber it's
not it's not worth it guys all right
everybody we were we will see you all
over at timcast.com thanks for hanging
out cheers